>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Bill Mesler: -- and I'm going
to be the commentator for today.
And I call this the nepotism
section because we're going to hear
from everybody who's ever held
Nathaniel's job before him.
You're in for a treat today.
But seriously, we're going to hear
from two wonderful astrobiologists.
And the first is David Grinspoon
who is the Senior Scientist
at the Planetary Science
Institute and a tremendous writer.
A lot of you would've been familiar
with his book, "Lonely Planets,
The Natural Philosophy
of Alien Life",
which won the PEN Award
for Research Nonfiction.
And he's also-- he has a new book
coming out in December called "Earth
in Human Hands" and be
sure you all buy that,
put that on your Amazon wish list.
I'm really excited to hear
David speak because I remember
as a young boy, reading Cosmo--
"Cosmos" by Carl Sagan,
the illustrated version.
And the one thing that always stuck
in my head were those pictures
of different forms of life that
could be found in the universe,
the hypothetical forms of life.
So, I think astrobiologist
have always been confronted
with that question, what is
life, when they begin to think
about what life could possibly be
like outside of our own planet.
And for most of us, I think,
we would answer that question
by saying what the
judge once famously said
about pornography that, "I
don't know how to define it
but I know it when I see it."
But I think an astrobiologist
would say that they would--
we might actually not be
able to use that definition.
We might not know it when we see it.
It could be so different
that it makes the depictions
of hypothetical life that
Sagan once put forward,
look rather mundane
and quite like our own.
And I think David is going
to talk about some scenarios
in which life could
exist in ways that, well,
we might not have even defined
it as life in ages past.
So, now I hand it over.
>> David Grinspoon: All right, thank
you very much Bill and thank you all
for making it back from lunch.
I'll try to keep you
awake while you digest.
And I just want to start
by saying it's a thrill
to be back here at the Kluge Center.
What a wonderful palace of
scholarly wonder this is
and my experience here was great.
I'd like to think that it's
not just nepotism but heritage
that is responsible for the
inclusion of the past chairs.
And who knows, in 20 years,
it might be pretty crowded
if there's a tradition here
of inviting them all back.
I'm here I think to represent
the astro part of astrobiology.
We've heard a lot of
bio and a lot of chem,
and I'm actually not someone the
traditional picture of an astronomer
that goes to a lonely called
mountain top and looks
through telescopes to try to figure
what's happening on distant orbs.
But I do what I do as I work
with teams that build spacecraft
and send them to other
planets and try to figure
out what the environments and the
histories of those planets are,
with the focus on the
question of habitability,
where might there be good places
for life elsewhere in the universe.
Which begs a lot of questions,
some of the questions we've been
grappling with so far today,
such as, as was mentioned in
that wonderful introduction,
what do we mean when we say life?
We maybe will know it when we
see it but is that good enough.
Now, as an astrobiologist,
of course,
what I really want is what
Spock has here, a tricorder,
so I could just point it at a
planet or a potential life form
and say, "It's alive, Jim.
Or, it's dead, Jim.
I'm not getting life form readings."
Is this thing working?
But we don't have one of those
yet and it's hard to even imagine
that we will have one of those
someday but maybe that's just
because our science of
astrobiology is in its infancy.
We are in the pre-discovery,
the pre-contact phase.
Maybe we'll always be in that phase
but obviously if we're ever not,
then our science will
be very different,
the way we approach
questions like this.
But as it is now, we
have a real paradox
with regard to this question.
I'm not going to go into detail
on what is life because I think,
actually, Steve-- Steven Dick
who follows me is going to talk
about this a little bit
more but I do want to point
out because it's relevant
to what I'm going to talk
about for a few minutes now
that which reminds me I need
to start my little timer here
because there isn't one otherwise.
Excellent.
I want to point out that the paradox
at the heart of this question
for scientists and scholars
and just conscious beings
in this pre-contact, pre-discovery
phase, which is that we're searching
for something that we
can't really define.
How do we define something when
we only have one example of it?
That's not really a very
scientifically credible thing to do.
If you're going to put
something in a classification
and say what its properties are then
hopefully you have multiple examples
of it.
Well, maybe we will someday.
But as of now, we're searching
for it and when we find it,
we'll be able to define
it much better.
But that's kind of weird,
searching for something
that you can't say what
it is until you find it.
So there is a little bit of a
paradox here and we grasp at things
like we'll know it when we see it.
But we're not completely stuck.
There are useful things we can do.
For example, we can
talk about searching
for habitable conditions elsewhere.
We can't say exactly in an ironclad
way perhaps exactly what life is,
but we can give our
sense of what it needs.
It seems like needing an energy
source is pretty safe, What--
however you define life, it's going
to have to eat or consume something
because if it's not doing
that, if it's not using energy
and metabolizing then, you know,
what good is it as a life form.
I don't know.
I think that's pretty
safe that it needs energy.
And then you get more
towards life as we know it.
It probably needs some liquid
medium, maybe it needs water, OK,
we're narrowing our
range of assumptions
but it still gives
us something concrete
and reasonable to search for.
So, the conditions of life is
something we can try to define
and search for even if we
don't quite know what it is.
We can also look for what
Spock would call life signs.
But that is life-- again, whatever
it is, it must be something
that somehow perturbs
its environment.
And there are more specific ideas
about this, not to get way into it,
but the idea of chemical
disequilibrium
that life is something that messes
with the chemical balance
of its home planet.
Certainly, Earth, the
one planet we know
of with life is flagrantly
disturbed by the presence of life
so that the atmosphere has
a composition that you--
as far as we could tell, I mean,
I'd put money on this even
while admittedly we're
in the pre-contact phase,
we don't know anything.
I'd put money on that we will never
find a planet with an atmosphere
as weird as Earth's
that doesn't have life.
That's a life sign, an
atmosphere with mixes of chemicals
that should not be there to
any other reasonable process.
So, we can talk about life signs.
And then-- And this is something
I'm barely going to scurred
on in this talk but certainly if
there was an alien species looking
at our planet, they would notice
also something else is happening
to our planet.
We can search for signs
of intelligent life.
And that's another
thing I put in quotes
because do we really
know what we're talking
about when we use those words?
It's interesting question.
But that's certainly something
I think in this whole spectrum
of things that we might find
elsewhere that betray the presence
of organisms we shouldn't
completely ignore.
So, there is another paradox,
couple of paradoxes we encounter
with this question, and that
is when we go toward scales
that are very small or very large.
We can come up with
reasonable definitions of life
but there's a strange
thing about life
when you go to different scales.
For instance, in this
graphic I've shown here.
This human being, I think we
would all agree, is alive.
It's composed of cells that I
think we would all agree are alive.
They're very similar
to living organisms
that aren't part of large organisms.
Those cells are composed
of molecules.
Most molecules probably
aren't really alive and
yet this DNA molecule, you might
be able to argue, is alive and
yet it's composed of atoms
that aren't, I would say.
Now, this paradox is often leads us
to the strange case of the viruses,
which a lot of people would say a
virus is not alive even though it
has a lot of the properties
of a living organism
because it cannot exist without
hijacking a larger living system.
But if you're going to
say that then you would--
I would submit, I have to
say human being is not alive
because we cannot exist
without a larger system
that we completely depend on.
Put a human being naked on the
moon and see how long they survive.
So, there's just some kind
of fun paradox as you get to.
Now, that's at the small scale,
what about at the larger scale?
We've been talking about the
origin of living organisms
but there are properties of
living systems that are larger
than organisms and there
are some ideas about this.
There's living systems
theory and Harold Morowitz
in the early '80s wrote
some interesting papers
about what he called
the-- what did he call it?
Basically the biological
properties of ecosystems that--
where he submitted that
life might be better defined
on that level rather than on
the individual organism level.
And this-- then goes all the
way up to what you've heard
of as the Gaia hypothesis, a much
abused and much maligned idea,
which I think is also
very profoundly important,
the idea that a planetary biosphere
has some properties similar
to those of living systems.
So in this graphic, you
see this sort of bug
where they're obviously
living organisms,
these birds and fish and things.
But then there are these-- for
instance, the dead log is dead
but the-- some of these other
organisms are completely dependent
upon it for their life.
So in some larger sense,
that decaying log is part
of this living entity,
this biosphere of the bug.
And, of course, you have the
case of the coral reefs where the
"dead parts" form the
skeletal structure that the
"living parts" are
completely dependent upon,
and so the whole thing
has a life fit
in a sense is larger
than the organisms.
And then you take that
to the larger scale,
this picture on the lower right,
reefs completely remake landscapes.
And so there's the boundary
between living and dead even
on that geographic landscape
scale is not completely clear.
And then you take that all the
way up to the planetary level,
and again, you're left
with this Gaia picture.
And the Gaia hypothesis, by the
way, as I said, it's been maligned
as the Earth is alive, the Earth
is a living organism in a sort
of new edgy way, which is nice
and poetic, I kind of like it.
But there's actually a more
scientifically useful way
of thinking about it which is
that the totality of the "living"
and "nonliving" parts of the
Earth function in a way so as
to achieve homeostasis that tend to
emphasize certain negative feedbacks
that keep the whole ball as it
were rolling in a way that keeps it
in that range of physical
conditions that are conducive
to the furtherance of life,
just as in your own body,
there's homeostasis going in
with your temperature and the pH
of your blood and all these things.
And it gives us a slightly
different picture of evolution.
It's actually a modification of
Darwinism because you realize
that it's not the case where
the environment is just changing
and life is just adapting to it.
But on a planetary scale,
life changes the environment
and so therefore it's a feedback
and a dance between the two
that can lead a planet to a very
different state than it would be
if it were not, in a certain
sense, taken over by life.
And as my colleague,
Colin Goldblatt put this,
the defining characteristic of
Earth is planetary scale life
and Earth teaches us
that habitability
and inhabitants are inseparable.
In other words, if you compare Earth
to other planets, which I'm going
to do a little bit more in a minute,
it jumps out at you how the life
of Earth dominate so many of
its physical characteristic,
not just the composition of
the atmospheres I mentioned
but the mineral balance
of the planet that about--
more than half of the
minerals on Earth exist
because of living systems,
the composition
of the ocean, the climate.
Even now, some people think the
composition of Earth's interior,
which affects the material
properties and convection
of the planet more
speculatively and the heat flow
of the planet are influenced by
and potentially controlled
to some extent by life.
So Earth is a planet
where habitability
and inhabitants have
become inseparable.
And we're not really sure
how far that goes back.
But when we compare
Earth to the neighbors,
Venus and Mars, it's
a stark difference.
Now, one other way to think about
life, I just want to mention.
This comes from the field of
non-equilibrium thermodynamics
and there's something called
a dissipative structure
that you've all seen because
you've seen "Dust Devils"
and at least films of tornados,
hopefully you've not
seen one really up close.
But you've also seen whirlpools
and vortices and not just on Earth.
On the upper right here, this
is on Venus, this polar vortex.
And a dissipate structure is a
structure that arises spontaneously
when you have the right kind
of flow of matter and energy
and matter organizes itself in
a way to facilitate that flow.
It's sort of spontaneous
order that arises from flow.
And you look at this
standing waves and this stream
on the bottom graphic here
and you can, if you want,
relate that to yourself
and think what am I?
Am I the atoms and molecules
that right now are part of me
but they're not going to
be part of me in the future
and they weren't always part
of me and yet I'm still me.
So, there's a sense in which that a
standing wave, which is a structure
that persists even as the
matter flows through it,
is an interesting model
for what a life form is.
And if you think of life as that,
as something that arises from flows
of matter and energy,
structures that evolve from that,
then again you can think of
the Earth and its biosphere
as the most complex dissipative
structure that we know.
And another example
of such a structure
that you're familiar with is a fire.
And this also has another--
captures another quality that I want
to mention because I think
it might be important
in how we think about
life on planets.
And that is-- think about when you
build a campfire and you're trying
to get it started, and at first it's
just sparks and it's really hard
to get it going, and
you have to keep--
stay there and keep
blowing on it and it does--
you know, you got sparks
and you've got your fuel
but it's quite disorganized
and it's really-- it's a pain.
But then you get it to a
point where it's going enough
and the coals are hot and it's
creating its own convection pattern
by sucking in air and the hot air
rising and then it's fueling itself
by pulling in oxygen and then
it becomes self-sustaining,
and it's a self-sustaining
dissipative structure
which is pulling in its own
fuel and taking advantage
of the cyclic motion of
nutrients through itself.
And it's possible that that's
what a global biosphere is.
And that I want to make the
distinction between the origin
of life that we've been discussing
which is, it seems to be discussed
as a local phenomenon, something
that happens one place or one region
but doesn't simultaneously
happen all around the planet.
And the origin of a global biosphere
that is a self-sustaining part
of the way a planet is operating,
which is clearly what we have here.
And when we look around
at other planets,
which is what I spend
my time doing and think
of the properties we're looking for,
we're really looking for the latter.
I think we're looking-- it's going
to be easier to find biospheres
or evidence of biospheres than
organisms or evidence probably
of organisms, although that
obviously depends on the case.
And it may be that life goes through
a stage initially where the origin
of life, that's like those
sparks that may fizzle
and die unless they're fed by
the right kind of cyclic flows.
But life can get to a point in
its existence on the planet that's
like that self-sustaining fire.
And I'm interested in that potential
difference between the origin
of life, meaning there's some
physical system that is behaving
like an organism in the ways we've
been discussing and the origin
of a global biosphere that might be
a property that a planet takes on.
In other words, in a sense,
maybe life is not just something
that happens on a planet but
something that happens to a planet
or something that a planet becomes.
So, this leads me to the musical
question, can a planet be alive?
And it's something I've
thought about a lot especially
with reference to comparative
planetology
which is really my day job.
And there's a growing field
among those who do study planets,
where what we really are interested
in is comparing the life stories
and environments of planets
to try to understand them,
not just as points in
time but as pathways,
as stories that collectively
illustrate properties
about what can happen to planets.
And one thing that can
happen to planets clearly
because it has here
is becoming alive.
So, how does this question of
whether a planet can be alive?
How is that illustrated or
what light can we shed on that
by looking around at the neighbors?
Well, we look at Mars
and never really--
ever since 1971, we've known
that Mars is a place that seems
to have been much more Earth-like.
I say '71 because that's when
Mariner 9, the first orbiter got
to Mars and really started and we
saw that it was the older parts
of Mars are covered
by dried up riverbeds.
And as we've explored Mars in depth
since then, we've learned much more
that indicates that Mars, when it
was young, was much more Earth-like.
And now, we're-- we have this
wonderful rover curiosity that's
slowly crawling across this lakebed,
it turns out it is a lakebed
as we thought from orbit of Gale
crater and starting to climb
up this mountain, Mount Sharp
and finding copious evidence
of a more watery, more wet,
more benign in terms of climate,
more Earth-like path than--
and just one bit of evidence.
You can see in this image
here, this rounded cobble,
these are river rocks,
where you couldn't tell.
But when you look at them up close
and you compare them to rocks
on Earth, these are rock-- this
is a place where water has flown.
And I won't go into
more detail about Mars.
Obviously, one can talk a
lot about this but, you know,
the punch line is that
Mars, when it was younger,
was a more Earth-like place.
And precisely those qualities
that we think would be conducive
to an origin of life as we
are, you know, imperfectly
but increasingly seem to understand
the requirements for that.
And there are some
problems with Mars.
The climate models don't quite work
to make it warm when it was young
but the geology tells
us it was watery
so there's still something
we're missing about Mars
but things are pointing
in that direction.
Now, when we go to the other
neighbor, Venus, as you know now,
Venus is hell on the surface.
It's far too hot for
our kind of life.
There's almost no water.
It's not a place you
would want to live today.
But in the past, our understanding
of Venus is more clouded, you know,
literally and metaphorically
than our understanding of Mars.
But what we have learned
so far points us to Venus,
being in the past, also a
much more Earth-like place.
And we have some designs for new
missions which we're hoping to fly
in the near future,
which are really designed
to take the measurements
that'll help us pin
down whether that's
really true about Venus.
But as far as we can tell, if
I had to draw you a picture
of the earliest environment
of Venus or not quite--
the second environment of Venus
after it was a fiery pit of impacts,
as all the planet started out.
But then once that
quieted down, I would say,
it would be sort of
like this picture.
And you notice this
picture is kind of murky
because our understanding is murky.
But basically, this is what Venus
and Mars probably both looked
like around the time we think the
origin of life happened on Earth.
They were water worlds and
they probably had black smokers
and things like that because the
heat flow was much higher then
and things point towards
origins that were conducive
to life on these planets.
And this makes me think that
the lesson, the punch line
of comparative planetology
in our region of space
and increasingly further a field is
that rocky planets have similar
origins in early environments,
that is not uncommon for rocky
planets to have wet condition,
not just wet but in places
where there are chemical flows
and interactions with
geothermal heat
and they all certainly
had organic molecules
because we're learning more and more
that organic molecules are
basically everywhere falling
from the sky and being synthesized.
And so, I would say that from what
we know about the origin of life
and its requirements, which
as you heard, are, you know,
still far from perfect knowledge.
But from what we know and from what
we know about the early environments
of these planets, there should've
been life on all three of them.
Not only do I say that because it
seems like conditions were right
on those planets but even if
it was something more rare,
another thing we've learned is
that the planets were all
exchanging materials back then.
There were bits getting blasted off
of one and landing on the other.
And microbes being the
hardy beasts that they are,
life would have been
transported from one to another.
So even if origin of life
is rare, you might not need
to have it indigenous to a planet.
If it happened on one
of the neighbors,
it could've easily spread.
So, similar origins
on early environments
and therefore what is rare
is not perhaps the conditions
for the origin of life but the
persistence of the conditions
to maintain life over
cosmological time scales.
That is over billions of
years, the ages of planets.
And that leads me back to
this question did the presence
of a global biosphere on Earth
help with that persistence?
So, maybe it's not-- we're
not just completely lucky.
Maybe life itself had a hand
in keeping Earth habitable.
Now, the very first
environment of all these planets,
as I mentioned, was hellacious.
We know they started off very
violently with a lot of collisions.
And this is the period of time
on Earth we call the Hadean,
which literally means hellish.
That was the first eon of
Earth history lasting up until
about 4 billion years ago.
And interestingly, I think
we can be pretty certain
that the Hadean was not a phase
unique to Earth, that Venus
and Mars had a Hadean around
the same time as Earth.
Now, did they also have an Archean ?
That's a really interesting
question.
So, here we have three
young terrestrial planets
and then something happened to
the middle one, to lead it to--
what we've been hearing about,
there was an origin of life
and I leave the details to the bio
and chemistry parts of astrobiology.
But clearly it happened in one
place and I have question marks
about whether it happened
in these other places.
If it didn't, then I think we
have to figure out why not.
But then, what I wonder is was
there another transition after that
to a global biosphere
on Earth, where the--
you could've have life
on all three planets
but it could've only
persisted on the one planet
where the geophysical conditions
were perhaps more friendly
for that continued set of
flows of nutrients and energy
on that stable surface environment
that allowed a global biosphere
to develop and take over and
then maintain its own existence.
Now, you've all seen the
geological time scale
where we have these different
ages and famously, you know,
the Jurassic is famous
because it's a movie star.
And after that, there's the
Cretaceous and the Tertiary
and all these are or now,
it's actually the Paleocene
and all these different ages.
And over on the right side of this
chart are the little, you know,
I say little, they've lasts for, you
know, a few millions years, nothing.
These are what we call the epochs.
And the epochs are not major
events in the life of the Earth.
They are important to the biota
who were alive at that time
because they're often
marked by extinction events,
climate changes, changes
in sea level.
There fluctuations that
change what can leave, where.
But they don't really
affect the planet that much.
Far over on the left are the eons.
There's only been four eons.
And the eons are interesting
to me as an astrobiologist
because I'm interested
in the relationship
between life and a planet.
And each of these eon
boundaries, I would suggest,
is a time when the character of the
planet fundamentally changed and,
in particular, the
relationship between life
and the planet fundamentally
changed.
The Hadean, it was dead
because it was just not a place
where you would want to live
or anything probably could
because it was-- there was
not a stable surface and now,
you were getting-- my colleague,
Kevin Zahnle refers to the Hadean
as an age of fire and brimstone
punctuated with blows to the head.
So that's the Hadean.
But the Archean is
roughly, and geologist
and geochemist will throw things
at me, you know, because I'm going
to make some crude statements.
But that's basically the trend.
The boundary between the Hadean
and the Archean is the origin
of life more or less 4 billion
years ago some people put it at 3.8.
That's when life-- when
the planet came alive.
Clearly, the other planets had a
Hadean, did they have an Archean?
That's an interesting question.
Now, I think the Proterozoic,
which is the next eon,
is arguably the time when
life took over the planet.
It's when we have the rise of oxygen
from the cyanobacteria
polluting the atmosphere
with all this nasty oxygen.
They were the original
bad actors who,
in the search for a
new energy source,
polluted the entire atmosphere and
collapsed the climate in, you know,
and just for their
own selfish purposes.
Anyway, so I think
the Proterozoic is
when the life perhaps
took over the planet.
The Phanerozoic which
started basically
over 500 million years ago is
the time when life got complex,
and animals and plants form and
life was not just multicellular
and all the forms of life, the
macrolife we're familiar with
and the fossils we're familiar with.
There was a seemingly
rather abrupt transition
and that's what we
call the Phanerozoic.
So each of these is sort of a
transition in the relationship
between life in the planet.
And as an astrobiologist, as I
said, I'm interested in these
because I can imagine, you know,
all these little changes
on the right side.
These epochs are unique to Earth.
They're Earth's random evolution.
But as you go to this left side this
major transitions, I would submit
to you that each one
of these is something
that astrobiologist could look
for on other planet
that-- OK, OK, I hear you.
That-- sorry, my phone is
telling me to hurry up.
That-- It's probably good advice.
That other planets
definitely had a Hadean.
If they had an origin of life,
we could say they had an Archean.
If life took over as it did on
Earth, that might be analogous
to our Proterozoic and if
life became complex then
that could be the Phanerozoic.
So these are all things
that astrobiologist talk
about looking for on other planets.
And so I think these eons
map into possibilities
for other planets whereas
the smaller boundaries,
the epochs stuff are clearly
just part of the Earth's story.
So, I want to just
mention one last transition
which is something is happening
to Earth now that's new
if you had been watching Earth
over the eons or/and you're a
patient alien watching Earth
from space.
You would notice suddenly things
had change that Earth lit up
and the atmosphere composition
and the ocean composition
or the ocean acidity is changing,
the land surfaces are changing,
these strange linear
clouds are striking
through the oceans
and across the sky.
There's something up on this
planet that it wasn't up before.
And the nature of that transition
is basically what I was studying
when I was here as the
astrobiology chair a few years ago,
and it's something that people had
been calling the Anthropocene epoch.
But I want to submit to you
that maybe it's not an epoch,
it might be an epoch boundary but
it might also be an eon boundary,
one of these major changes.
Why would I say that?
I think it's a fundamental change
in the relationship between life
and the planet because cognitive
processes, making things, tool use,
are changing the planet
in profound ways.
And life has changed the
planet many times in the past
but cognitive processes being
involved in the functioning
of the planet, that's
something new and very strange.
And if it persists, I think arguably
as significant even as the origin
of life and therefore
could be an eon boundary.
We won't know for hundreds
of millions of years this--
my idea cannot be disproven
even by the remote,
remote descendants
from-- of anyone alive now
so I feel pretty confident
in making it.
But anyways, so here's dead planets,
here's planets with the origin
of life, here's planets
where some of them have gone
through a transition
to a global biosphere
and just maybe there's a
class of planets out there
where this transition to cognitive
function as a part and technology
as a part of the way the
planet functions has become
something long-term.
And there's some fascinating
arguments that I don't have time
to go into now about whether that's
possible, whether intelligent--
"intelligence" is something
that always will limit itself
by giving itself the power to
wipe itself out or could we be
like the dinosaurs that
had a space program
and therefore survived
the extinction
by pushing the asteroid
out of the way.
There are ways in which you
could imagine technology leads
to longevity.
And that, by the way, I'm not
going to talk about that more now
but this allows me to make a plug
for the book "Earth in Human Hands"
which is in fact the project I
was working on when I was here
as the astrobiology chair and I
just wanted to show it off not just
because I want to make a plug for it
but because my good colleagues here
at the Kluge Center, I think
they had a sneaking suspicion
that I wasn't really doing
anything because why did this take
so long so I want to say, "Aha!
See." It's a book.
"Earth in Human Hands", thank you.
It-- by the way, it's being
published this December,
it's being printed now,
this is an advanced galleon.
For those of you in town, I'm having
a lunch party at Busboys and Poets,
December 7th, please come join us.
And getting back and I'm ending
now, but getting back quickly
to this geologic timescale with all
these transitions I talked about,
I would submit that this
new boundary we're going
through could be an eon boundary
and I propose the name Sapiezoic,
for what we're entering,
the phase of Earth
that is characterized by wisdom.
Now, that seems sort of arrogant.
In fact, it was arrogant of the
Neos to name us Homo sapiens
which means wise ape
because if you look
at our behavior now
we're not doing so well.
But my point is that the only
way it wound become an eon is
if we get our acts
together and persist.
And so it's an aspirational title.
If we don't get our act
together then it's not going
to be the Sapiezoic, it is going
to be just a little
bleep of an Anthropocene.
But I think our history, our long
history suggest that we are species
that when faced with extinction
which we have been before reinvents
itself and uses its innate gifts
for communication and
creativity and collaboration
to imagine new futures
and create them.
And so, we certainly have
a rough century ahead of us
but when I take this
big picture view,
personally I'm not at
all devoid of hope.
And finally coming back with
my last slide to astrobiology,
the potential for Sapiezoic
transitions I think is one
that we also at least have to
consider on other planets along
with these other transitions
that I mentioned.
And if that is the
case, then when we--
there's another way to think about
finding intelligent life out there.
We don't have to assume they're
sending signals to us which I kind
of a weird assumption like,
why should they, right?
I mean there's one kind of
alien life you could imagine
that might want to.
There are all kinds of alien life--
kinds of alien life
that you could imagine
that would have no interest
just like you have no interest
in discussing philosophy with
a frog-- or maybe you do, but.
But what's cool about if
there are planets out there
that where this transition is
happening then we can find them even
if they're not trying to talk to us.
It may be that there are three
types of exoplanets, dead ones,
living ones and sapien ones.
And I'll stop there, thank you.
[ Applause ]
Shall we?
>> Bill Mesler: Yeah.
Oh, do you want your
questions now or?
>> David Grinspoon: No
I don't want questions.
>> Bill Mesler: Why don't we do them
both afterwards, right, with the--
That was an amazing talk.
And, you know, he's too
humble to mention this
but he has a new book
coming out in December.
[ Laughter ]
"Earth in Human Hands".
Our next speaker is another
astrobiologist and a historian,
and he was the long time
Chief Historian at NASA.
Before that he spend 20 years
at the US Naval Observatory
and he probably knows more about the
development of exobiology as a field
than anybody else out there.
He's going to talk about
that among other things.
One of the things he's going
to speak about is something
that really caught my eye and
that is the idea of panspermia,
the idea that life on Earth
may have originated elsewhere.
So he's going to become
the second speaker
after Steve Benner to
mention panspermia.
And I think 30 years ago if you
were at a conference of the origin
of life and two people
had brought up panspermia,
the next speaker would
have been in a sailor suit
and trying to sell you Dianetics.
But now it has become-- once
again become a mainstream thing.
And I'm not advocating
it or arguing against it
but I think it's fascinating
because it illustrates
that science doesn't really travel
in that straight diagonal line
that I think most of us imagine
when we think about science,
this idea that we're going from
ignorance into illumination
and it's just this easy clear path.
I think sometimes science zigzags
and panspermia is one of those ideas
that a century ago or in the late
19th century it would have been a
widely accepted idea and it was
two of the proponents or two
of the most important
scientist at the time,
Lord Kelvin and Svante Arrhenius.
And it was so widespread because
the scientist had a hard time
reconciling Darwinian evolution with
what they thought at that time was
in Earth that was only a
hundred million or even tens
of millions of years old.
So panspermia fell into ill
repute but it's not come back
and I'm interested into
hearing more about that.
So, here's Steven Dick.
[ Applause ]
>> Steven Dick: Well
thanks a lot Bill.
And as with David and Nathaniel of
course I have to say how great it is
to be back at the Kluge Center
here at the Library of Congress
where I spend a fabulous
year a couple of years ago,
a very enjoyable year, so thanks
Nathaniel for having me back.
And also thanks to Jim
Green and Mary Voytek
over at NASA Headquarters who
fund this great Blumberg Chair
in astrobiology which has
the purpose of looking
at the humanistic aspects of
astrobiology and I was very pleased
to see the latest astrobiology
strategy document that they
on appendix beyond the
natural sciences about the role
of the humanism-- or
humanities and social sciences.
So, that subject is coming
into its own in astrobiology.
I think it's really an
important role for the humanities
and social sciences to examine
the impacts of astrobiology just
that it's been for the Human
Genome Project these days.
I think it's all part of the
larger need to relate science
to society and-- which I think
especially we need to do these days.
Well, when I proposed this title
for my talk, Nathaniel said,
"You can't do that in 20 minutes."
And he's right of course.
If I were going to do this
in an hour long lecture I
would do something like this.
With more time I would sort
of systematically layout some
of the metaphysical and ontological
and epistemological issues,
in the origin of life studies I
would clarify its central concepts
such as the meaning what is life
as we've been hearing about.
I would talk about some of
the methodological issues
and how they limit our approaches
to the problem in the same way
that Martin Harwood has
recently written a book about--
arguing that what we know about
the universe really is shaped
by the tools that we
have for astronomy
and I think the same is true
about origins of life studies.
And I would examine the societal
impact, but I'm not going to be able
to do all that so let me focus on
just two or three of three briefly.
Issues that really pop out of
me when I wrote the history
of the extraterrestrial life debate
in my book "The Biological Universe"
and I think they're just as
relevant now as they were then
because these are general
philosophical issues.
It's always been interest in me--
to me also I want to say that one
of the earliest goals of the
space program was exobiology
as it was called in those
days and the search for life
in the universe thanks to
pioneers like Joshua Lederberg
and Jerry Soffen and Carl
Sagan and many, many others.
And I think we-- you cold easily
argue that the search for life
in the universe has
been an important driver
of the space program certainly when
it comes to the exploration of Mars.
Some of the ocean worlds that we're
now talking continue to be drivers
of the entire space program.
Everybody, when I was at NASA
you got around giving talks.
Everybody wants to know
about life on other worlds
so astrobiology really is at the
forefront not only in science
but also in the public
interest I would say.
So, let me begin with a conceptual
issue that is really at the heart
of everything we've heard today.
If we've going-- if we were
going to search for life on Mars,
we had to have some
idea what to search for.
So, the first of the
philosophical issues was raised
almost immediately.
That is, what is life?
That's the question that's
been in the background
of all the papers we've heard today.
Many people have tried to answer
that question, and you'll be happy
to hear that I'm not going to try
to answer that question today.
After all, my background is more
in astronomy than it is biology
but I do want to talk about the
controversy over the question
because it's similar to some of
the questions we have in astronomy.
And in fact, all of these
historical and philosophical issues
that you see here are ones that
you find in astronomy also.
Someone recently quote that
life is what's leftover
after you eliminate
everything that's not alive.
Somehow I don't think
that's really very helpful
but the question is an old one,
it's contemplated by biologist
and biochemist physicist like
Schrodinger over several centuries.
That history reads like
a mirror of each period
when the question was
asked as biologist try
to determine the physical
basis for life
with the intention turning
successively to protoplasm,
the protein enzyme, the
virus, the gene and the cell.
And by 1937 already the British
biologist Norman Pirie was arguing
that the terms life and
living were really meaningless
that he transition from
nonliving to living was comparable
to the gradual transition from
green to yellow in the spectrum it's
like seeing a rainbow, you know,
when do you transition from one
to the other or like going from
acid to alkaline in chemistry except
that life itself could
not be defined
in terms of only one variable.
Well, today the debate about the
origins of life is at the level
of the molecular assembly of life.
We often see this NASA
definition of life
as a self-sustaining chemical system
capable of Darwinian evolution.
But I think there's a consensus
that no single definition
of life is totally satisfactory,
some philosophers and scientist
like Carol Cleland
and Chris Chyba say
that they've argued repeatedly
beginning with a series of papers
in 2002 that all attempts to define
life were fundamentally misguided
in the absence of a general living,
general theory of living systems
which of course we don't have.
Other philosopher such as Kelly
Smith call this stance the
definition of pessimism and
argue that you don't need
to have a universal definition of
life to have a working definition
for any given circumstance.
In other words, there has to
be a balance between definition
of pessimism and pragmatism.
And I really tend to
come down on that side
on Kelly Smith's side
for several reasons.
First of all, because we
really can't help ourselves
from defining life, can we?
Just as we can't help ourselves
from defining a lot of other things
like say planet to take a
random example from astronomy.
Secondly, institutions like NASA
of course need an operational
definition of life
if they're going to search for it.
The latest astrobiology strategy
document specifically says the
definitions of life and
function and evidence all--
those kinds of things
shape our research
and therefore we need them even
though we don't need to obsess
over them and they
need to be elastic.
We need to be able to adjust them.
In astronomy, we think
of the controversy surrounding
the question, is Pluto a planet?
You've seen the amazing images
coming from the New Horizons mission
which David is also
writing a book about.
But of course whether or not
Pluto is a planet depends
on your definition.
And the International Astronomical
Union 10 years ago last month
decided that the answer was no
that Pluto was not a planet based
on a rather arbitrary set
of conditions I think
some people would say.
It was a compromise among
the astronomic communities
that define Pluto as a dwarf
planet and then declared
that a dwarf planet
was not a planet.
Well I voted for the dwarf planet
part but I've always thought
that dwarf planet should
be a class of planet,
but it's not by definition.
So, the point is though
that it was defined in a way
that reflected these different
astronomical communities even though
it disappointed some scientist
like Alan Stern who's the PI
from the New Horizons
mission, not to mention a lot
of other school kid
who were disappointed.
It was-- an interesting
cultural phenomenon really.
But you'll notice that
arguments over definition
of a planet didn't keep New Horizons
from having a spectacular
mission, right?
Alan likes to point out that Pluto
doesn't care if it's a planet
or a dwarf planet so we could
go on and study it anyway.
And the same is true of
the definition of problems
with things like species.
A common definition of species
is organisms that can interbreed,
belong to the same species.
Well we now know that Homo sapiens
and Neanderthal interbreed, right?
So, most of us are
1 to 3% Neanderthal.
So instead of throwing out the
concept of species we expand
or adjust the definition.
And the same isn't true--
is also true of intelligence
David mentioned intelligence
which a study people like to
scurred by talking about the search
for extraterrestrial technology,
not intelligence then they don't
have to define intelligence.
And I remember right
here at the Library
of Congress a few years ago
asking the philosopher John Searle
about the concept of intelligence.
He said, "Forget intelligence.
The big question is consciousness."
And of course nobody knows how to
define consciousness either, right?
There's no consensus definition.
So, we all settle for
operational definitions that apply
to the specific task at hand.
So, people like Carol Cleland
and philosophers I think have a good
point when they say that, you know,
we can't have a universal
definition of life in the absence
of living systems theory.
I certainly agree with that but we
do need operational definitions.
Now of course those operational
definitions can get you into a lot
of trouble especially if you
choose the wrong definition
when you go off searching for say
life of Mars and that was the case
with the Viking biology experiments,
all of which relied on a definition
of life based on metabolism.
Gil Levin, one of the principal
investigators still believe
that he fond life on Mars,
claim that's no longer
so much completely dismissed as it
used to be given what we now know
about the surface chemistry of Mars.
For many years that result was
trumped by what's called the GC/MS,
the Gas Chromatograph Mass
Spectrometer experiment
because it show that there were
no organic molecules on Mars
at those two landing sites
where the Viking Landers landed.
So, if you have no organic molecules
you can't have life, right?
So that sort of wipes out all
the experiments on metabolism
and in fact a biochemical definition
of life trumped all the other
metabolic experiments until we found
out more about the role of
perchlorates on the surface of Mars.
So the lesson of Viking seems to be
that experiments should be designed
with multiple definitions
of life in mind.
Now the best way to define
life of course would be
to actually find some on
Mars or your [inaudible] some
of these other places
and compare it to Earth.
In that case if it was
truly a second genesis,
we might have the beginnings
of a universal biology similar
to a universal physics
that we think we have now.
And that's the second issue I
want to address the aspirations
for universality by
which I mean two things.
Is there a universal biology
as there is a universal
physics, and is life universal?
In other words, is it spread
throughout the universe?
So in this respect I
think there's no doubt
that the space program
really catalyzed aspirations
for universality in
both of these ways.
Implicitly or explicitly those
at the intersection of exobiology
and origins of life expressed
interest in the desire
for a universal biology, one
that might be a more general
than terrestrial life.
In the Soviet Union, Oparin
called exobiology and the origins
of life the inseparable connection.
And Stanley Miller
did the same thing.
And here we saw the Urey-Miller
experiment this morning.
Some of you may notice that I have
1952 whereas I forget who it was
who showed it this
morning, had 1953.
I think that's the difference
and this is an interesting thing
about when is the discover made, is
it made when the experiment is done
or is it made when the
publication comes out?
Well in this case the experiment was
done in '52 but it's always cited
as '53 because that's
when the public--
that's an interesting thing
in science I've done
a whole book on that.
Anyway, both of these scientists
said that exobiology and origins
of life are the inseparable
connection.
Origins of life studies
quickly became a central focus
of exobiology bringing
into the field scientist
such as Melvin Calvin.
Once interviewed Melvin Calvin in
his office at Berkeley best known
for his Nobel Prize and it
happen to do with photosynthesis.
But Calvin said in his
mind there was no question
about the Darwinian behavior of
molecules and if that were true,
that meant it must be true
in the entire universe.
His student Cyril Ponnamperuma
said basically the same thing.
If we can understand how it
began here we'll know something
about how it began and if it began
out there and if it's repeated
in a staggering number
of planetary systems
in our galaxy, or in
our universe even.
Now that was written in 1972
when there were no other
solar systems known aside
from our own, right?
Of course now we know
that they're everywhere.
So in short this space program--
my point is the space program
catalyzed the integration of origin
of life and extraterrestrial life
studies as theories and experiments
that were previously viewed just
in the context of life beginning
on Earth were increasingly seen
in extraterrestrial context
integrating these two fields
of study.
Now, these conclusions
about universality
of really hide a deep
metaphysical preconception
and that is the question of chance
and necessity in the origin of life.
I think it's a real tribute
to the scientist involved
that they recognize
their preconceptions.
In fact, the philosophical question
that dominated the problem of origin
of life beyond Earth was exactly
that, what was the role of chance
and necessity in the
formation of life?
After all that question hinge the
whole enterprise of exobiology,
what we now call astrobiology,
because if life was just a chance
occurrence and was very rare then,
you know, it might never happen
again no matter how big the universe
was or how much time you had.
In my mind the two prototypes
for the debate over chance
and necessity are Jacques
Monod and Christian de Duve
of here you see Jacques
Monod a French biologist.
Monod and de Duve both
are Nobel Prize winners.
Monod was awarded the
Nobel Price in 1965
for explaining the
genetic regulation
of protein synthesis in cells.
And he drew on the latest
results on molecular biology
to illustrate how chance
predominated
in all aspects of life's
development.
And he wrote a classic
volume called "Chance
and Necessity" written in 1971.
And he wrote this--
famously wrote this phrase
which you often see quoted, the
universe was not pregnant with life,
nor the biosphere with man.
Our number just came up
in a Monte Carlo game.
So, he came to that view because
of what he called the revelation
and the disappointment that the
sequences composing the insulin
protein showed no general
law of assembly,
only the blind workings of chance.
Many scientists since
that time have agreed
with him including some astronomers
like Fred Hoyle who famously argued
that the origin of life by
chance was about as likely
as a 747 aircraft being assembled
spontaneously from a junkyard,
pretty, pretty good image.
He thought it was vastly
more probably
that life had been assembled
by a cosmic intelligence.
But before the religious people
could get to excited he emphasize
in his opinion it was not a
supernatural intelligence,
but that's another subject.
And in his book "Advocating
Panspermia" of Francis Crick tended
to agree that life could not have
risen by chance here on Earth.
Well, a quarter century after
that, here's Christian de Duve,
who just died last year, wrote
a book called "Vital Dust,
Life as a Cosmic Imperative".
And he argued just the opposite
from his Nobel Prize
French colleague Monod.
And he's a very well-known
biochemist also best known
for his discoveries related
to the structure and function
of organization of a cell.
And he was most impressed with
the organic molecules then being
discovered in space.
So it's interesting how these
two came through their ideas
about chance and necessity.
It was based on things that were
currently happening sometimes
on their own research.
So he wrote, as you see here,
done in the organic cloud
and here he's talking about these
organic molecules being discovered
in space which we now know exist all
over in interstellar molecular
clouds that they were everywhere
and the conclusion
seem to him inescapable
that where the conditions are
similar to those that prevail
on our planet that
there would be life.
And he went so far as to
say that those who claim
that it's highly improbable
just have a look closely enough
at the chemical realities.
So there you have two, you know,
pretty smart guys both
a Nobel Prize winners
with totally different
points of view on that.
OK. I think it's one of
the hallmarks of exobiology
and now astrobiology that is
practitioners place their faith
in more in necessity than in chance
or at least a high probability
of the origin of life
under proper conditions.
It was their most basic
metaphysical presupposition.
Otherwise, they wouldn't waste their
time searching for like, right?
If you don't think it's
very likely you're not going
to put much time into it.
I happen to agree that this
is a good supposition--
presupposition partly because
as we've heard life seems
to have risen so quickly
on the Earth.
We've heard this morning
several times
about the discoveries
just announced last week
about the life 3.7 billion years
old just after the Hadean period
that David was talking about the
heavy bombardment of the Earth,
those fossil and those were
fossilized stromatolites
like the ones that we're-- has
Steve passed around this morning
but these were from 3.7
billion years ago stromatolites
from the issue of rocks
southwest coast of Greenland.
So that's less than a billion
years after the Earth was formed
and you already had life beginning.
And that seems to be also to argue
for a role for panspermia maybe
that the spreading of life
throughout the universe
or at least giving life a head start
by spreading complex
organic molecules
which we know are ubiquitous in
these interstellar molecular clouds
that so impressed Christian de Duve.
Beyond a life's rapid origin on
Earth the idea of necessity seems
to be also to be reinforced by
the fact that the physical law
as we know now that the physical
laws of nature are universal
and that what happened here
opt to ought to happen there.
That's certainly is a presupposition
but it's a recognized presupposition
that seems to work pretty well,
it certainly worked
for the planets, right?
I could remember prior to 1995,
people saying we don't know
of about any other planets outside
of our solar system and we didn't.
But with this presupposition
a lot of people, you know,
said the laws of physical
laws of nature universal,
what happens here happens there,
lo and behold, there they are.
Not only-- I mean, they're
virtually everywhere even
around as we've heard recently
around red dwarf stars in fact
which is what Proxima Centauri is
the closest star to us as planets.
Now of course they don't have life.
Most of those don't have
life but some of them are
in their habitable zones
and could have life.
That's a metaphysical presupposition
and with the discovery of a stream
of files that we've heard
about this morning in the form
of hydrothermal vents
and deep underground,
we know now that proper conditions
are much broader than we thought
in the past and we
also know that the idea
of a habitable zone
has been expanded.
I mean, who would have thought
that the moons of Jupiter
and Saturn were in
the habitable zone?
Well, they are, right?
They're way out there,
don't get much solar light
but they have tidal
heating and they--
which allows them to
have liquidations
which means life could exist.
That's not to say that it will
be like ours, far from it,
there'll be diversity
just as there is diversity
in the planets that
we're finding now.
They are not, not all like ours
by any means, the gas giants
and orbiting near in their
stars and that sort of thing.
So there is a lot-- there will be
a lot of diversity I would predict.
But this idea of universal law
is producing similar outcomes
with diversity has been
proven over and over again.
It remains a presupposition, it's
true, but I think it's a good one.
Some presuppositions are better than
others so that's the presupposition,
the metaphysical presupposition
behind astrobiology that's one
of them.
Well, that gives rise to even
deeper of metaphysical questions,
why is the universe
Bio-friendly to start with.
Do we just happen to live in
a universe where the contents
of nature are such that
the galaxies, planets
and stars and life can form?
We could have life we don't
think unless we had the planets
and the starts.
But the conditions of the
universe have to be right.
The contents-- physical
contents had to be right
for those things to happen.
Is life in some way one
of the fundamental
entities of the universe?
Here you get into what some people
call the anthropic principle
which I would rather call
the biocentric principle.
And talking about that, people
ask is there some deep connection
between life and the very
structure of the universe.
The questions like this really
land all the more important I think
to astrobiology because
it's going to--
astrobiologists are going to
determine just how abundant life is
in the universe and whether
it is a basic principle
or whether we are a fluke.
Some argue that the biological
universe may not be the result
but the cause of the
physical universe
which is a pretty strong statement
but maybe life is more fundamental
than we've ever realized.
Here's a quote from
Freeman Dyson who is known
for some ideal ideas that's true
but also a very well-known physicist
saying that it almost seemed
as if the universal
knew we were coming
and he predicts a bright prospects
where a future-oriented science
that would look to the future rather
than the past and would admit life
and intelligence on an equal
footing with general relativity
as factors influencing the
evolution of the universe OK.
So we've come quite of a
long way from the origins
of life we were talking about this
morning but I think this points
up that origin of life could not
have occurred unless the universe
was Bio-friendly.
So this takes you from one end
of the argument to the other.
So, I think my time is up but you'll
see that I have after all touch
on quite a few of these just in a
cursory way of these issues except
for the last one and I just want
to say a word or two about that.
In the end we still
don't know whether
or not life is abundant
in the universe.
It remains perhaps I would say
the greatest question in science
and in the history of
science but if there is life
out there it's I think it's prudent
that we prepare for that discovery
which in the long term could change
our world views in the same way
that we were changed
by the Copernican
and the Darwinian systems.
And I say that even if the universe
is only full of microbes which a lot
of people think might be the case.
After all if you look at here
on Earth it took us a long time
to get microbes to
tillage a life, right?
So, the challenge of
the societal impact
of astrobiology is a very
large topic and that's
where I spent my year at the Library
of Congress studying and if you want
to know more about that, there
is the book that I edited
on this subject based on
the Bloomberg symposium
that we had two years ago.
This is published by
Cambridge University Press
so you might think it's
out of reach in terms
of the price but actually it's not.
If you go on to Amazon right now
you can get it for $2 and 98 cents.
So, that's a bargain.
And I think you'll find it
stimulating on a wide variety
of issues not just
argues life but a lot
of these other societal
issues beyond.
It's one of the great things about
astrobiology that you can talk
about not just the chemistry and
the physics and the astronomy
but also the humanities, the
social sciences, theology all kinds
of things when you talk
about societal impact.
So thank you, I'll
think I'll stop there.
[ Applause ]
>> Bill Mesler: After you, oh.
Do you guys want to sit?
>> Steven Dick: Yeah I guess.
>> Bill Mesler: And we'll
move quickly in the questions
because you've heard
two wonderful talks
and I'm sure we're
going to have a lot.
Anybody? Right there.
I think he is bringing
you a microphone.
>> My question is for Dr. Grinspoon.
And I was really intrigued
by your concept
of the cognitive intelligence for
not only Earth but the Galaxy?
And would you please
develop that a little more?
Does this mean that we create
life, true until action?
>> David Grinspoon: Not necessarily
although it's interesting.
One twist of this transition
if there is a transition
towards cognitive life being part
of the planet which I would
I argue there could be.
One interesting twist on that,
that I didn't have a chance
to mention is some of the
work we've been hearing
about here gives us the potential
to also become the engineers
of evolution and that's another
way in which a Sapiezoic eon
on a planet could be defined
because you could argue the
natural selection is no longer,
is no longer full stop that even
the Darwinian evolution that's going
on in the planet now is
in an environment a global
environment that's perturbed
by the cognitive for better
or worst the technological
and industrial activities
of humanity.
Now, that's always
true that evolution
of species have affected the
evolution of other specie
but I would maintain there's
a fundamentally different kind
of process going on.
So what I was talking about
specifically was just looking
at the mechanisms of change on
the planet and what I was doing
when I was here as the
chair was trying to work
from a planetological point of view
at this transition that is happening
to Earth now and try to define
that in a way that's not just
human beings are doing this
but is there a more abstract
way that we could possibly map
into planetary history that might
obtain on other planets as well
and that's where I focus on this.
You know, you could
argue that cognitive,
that nervous systems are
something that will evolve
on other planets if life evolves.
I won't go into now but there
is a good argument for that
and therefore even though
intelligence is hard
to define you could
argue that something
like human-type intelligence in some
of this aliens aspects would
evolve elsewhere and technology
and therefore if it got to the
point where it was affecting its--
the evolution of its planet
which I think it has here then
that might be a Sapiezoic
elsewhere and a sort
of not human centered
but more abstract sense.
>> This is for Steve.
I'm not an atrobiologist
so-- I'm a historian.
And I want to raise two questions.
Is there a slight possibility
that we approach this
question from death?
In other words, we'll take death
as an opposite of life and see
that opens up, it'd be a discussion.
>> Steven Dick: That opens up what?
>> It'd be a discussion.
If we approach life
from death, seen death,
maybe as an opposition understand
to which that response some
of this notions, I'm just trying
it I don't have any answer.
>> Bill Mesler: That sounds like
the idea of the absence of life--
>> Steven Dick: Yeah.
>> Bill Mesler: --
being as describe life.
>> Steven Dick: Yeah.
>> So with-- in terms of
that definition of life,
I don't think it's an exclusive
terrain of astrobiologist.
I think it's a fundamental question
that we'll have to face even outside
of the academy in which mythologies,
religion, spirituality, act--
going to create their own
contestations in which--
>> Bill Mesler: So how is that a
challenge for astrobiology the fact
that you are sharing a landscape
that is a metaphysical landscape,
not astrobiology but origin
of life and, you know,
in talking about what
is life I mean.
>> Steven Dick: Well, I
think it goes to the question
of our place in the universe.
The question about the death,
my view on that would be I
don't see how it helps that much
because if death is
the absence of life
and you don't know what
life is I don't see how it--
how that helps, unless
you're talking about it
in a more metaphysical
sort of a way.
But in general, and not
in a scientific way,
but in general I would
say that you're talking
about an even broader definition
of life as the life that we live,
right, not the life that's
originated, the origins of life.
So I think astrobiology
helps us in terms of figuring
out what our places in the universe
because it's a very
different universe.
If we are the only life on this,
you know, in our solar system
and even in the entire universe.
We know that in our own solar system
that there's, you know, we're--
I would say almost certainly
the only intelligent life.
But if we-- the only life and in
the galaxy of it is extremely rare.
I guess it's a different sort
of view on life in general as,
you know, as you said as
sort of more metaphysical,
spiritual phenomenon
then if life is common.
We'll have to, you know, if life--
intelligent life out there is
common we have to share the universe
with that intelligence and learn
how to interact with it whereas is--
if we are the only intelligent
in the universe then, you know,
the universe is-- I wouldn't say--
I wouldn't want to put in a way of--
we should exploit the universe then.
But the universe is, you
know, very different place
and I think it puts more emphasis
on our stewardship of this planet
and any other planets that we go
to and all the ethical questions
that arise if we're the only life.
Either way it's a very
sobering thought.
There'll be lots of ethical
questions too if there's lots
of intelligence out there or even
if there are microbes out there.
All kinds of ethical questions
about, you know, what do you--
how do you treat an alien microbe,
questions about forward
contamination
and back contamination.
Of course NASA has robust
programs to deal with that
in a very short-term but they
have nothing to do with it
in the longer term about
what you do about even
about microbes if you discover them.
Yup.
>> Bill Mesler: And David.
>> David Grinspoon: Yeah.
Just quickly I would add that
there might actually be a pragmatic
interpretation of your
question for astrobiology.
I've actually thought about does it
make sense to think of the search
for death in the universe.
We talk about a search for life
in the universe and it might--
in one way which is of
course you can have life
without death I take
in our understanding.
And if you look at the chances
of life existing or having exist
in other worlds in the universe and
you do the math, there are a lot
of solutions that suggest there
are probably a lot more planets
where there was life
once than there are--
than planet where there
is life right now.
So if we thought about how do to
identify planets where life had died
out and not just where it exist
now, that would be maybe one way
to interpret a search
for death in the universe
and it might actually be
something that gives us a lot more,
a lot more to search for.
>> Steven Dick: It might be more
difficult than a simple life.
>> Bill Mesler: Ladies first.
I'll get you next.
OK.
>> Wasn't the [inaudible]
into the question of existence
of consciousness without body
molecules and is that life?
And where is that connection?
>> Bill Mesler: You mean his
idea of planetary intelligence?
>> I'm talking about consciousness.
As we know it, it exist within our
lives, our molecule structure but--
>> David Grinspoon:
That's a tough one.
As Steve mention I think you
were quoting John Searle?
>> Steven Dick: Yah, so.
>> David Grinspoon: You
know, forget intelligence,
so he wants to go for consciousness.
I mean, the fact is we
don't know what it is.
We sense, we experience it, we have
some ideas that we might be able
to induce it in computers.
And so, is it something we
can talk about searching for?
I mean, I scurred that one.
I said intelligence
I put it in quotes
because these are problematical
terms
if you really want to get into it.
Is it something that could exist
beyond a physical body, I mean,
as Bones might say on
Star Trek, you know,
"I'm a doctor damn it not a
philosopher or a theologian."
I haven't the foggiest.
>> Steven Dick: Or Fred
Hoyle's Black Cloud
which was probably conscious.
>> David Grinspoon: Right, right.
>> Steven Dick: It can communicate.
>> David Grinspoon: Yeah.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> -- planets without
bodies, or lives,
or molecules as we know
them, just consciousness.
>> Steven Dick: Well, that's
thinking out of the box.
>> And would that be life?
>> Bill Mesler: And right here.
>> Thank you.
I want to ask David about the large
synoptic telescope and whether
or not we could imagine elsewhere in
the galaxy a more advanced version
of this telescope and whether
or not they could detect
life in this solar system.
>> David Grinspoon: Absolutely.
Some-- you know, we're
just at the beginning
of the exoplanet revolution
where we can know something
about the planets in
other solar systems.
And just the fact that we know there
are planets on other solar systems,
that alone is a revolutionary bid
of information that we didn't have,
you know, and I think
anybody in this room was born.
It's brand new.
Now we're at the stage where
we're starting to learn something
about those planets, but
we're in early stage of that
and we can imagine
massive space telescopes
with massive occultation structures
that allow us to, you know,
and do direct imaging of
other planets and, yeah.
I think there are quite
possibly civilizations out there
that have telescopes that can see
things like the lights on our planet
at night and can--
with spectrometers notice that
there are changes happening
in our atmosphere.
I wouldn't put it pass them.
>> Bill Mesler: Right there.
>> Today we discussed the
chemistry of life, biology of life
and they want to comment
on astrophysics of life.
So we leave next to an
active star called the Sun.
And the Sun, yup, it causes the
profound effects on our planet.
And if we want to find life we want
to find life through the interaction
of solar effects or solar
winds, solar flares,
coronal mass ejections [inaudible]
was the atmosphere was the chemicals
produced by life in the atmosphere.
So-- and instead of probably looking
for life itself which is represented
by pretty complex molecules, we
want to look for the signatures
of prolife, or probiotic chemistry
that we talked about without
which life is impossible.
So might be it's our best bet to go
after the strongest signal possible
to go-- to look for the-- to
use our telescopes intelligently
to find those environments that have
a pretty strong signal was a nearby
host stars that interact with those
atmospheres that pregnant was life
and basically to go after
pregnancy relative for life.
>> Steven Dick: Yeah.
That's a burgeoning
field in astrobiology.
It's the next big thing I would say
what they call biosignatures looking
for, you know, James Webb Space
Telescope, the successor or sort
of the successor to Hubble will
be able to look at the atmospheres
of planets and see if they
have oxygen or methane or some
of these other things that
might be indication of life.
But you're right also in the sense
that astrobiology differs from--
exobiology when it was founded was
almost entirely origins of life.
Astrobiology deals not
just with origins of life
but with the entire system, the
entire environment, the Sun and the,
you know, and the planets and
how they interact and what's
in equilibrium and
what's in disequilibrium
and then this whole idea of
biosignatures stems from that too.
So that's-- you're going to hear
lot more about that in the future.
>> Bill Mesler: We have time
for just one more question.
Yeah?
>> Thank you.
So you could sort of-- in
the discussions you're having
about detecting life elsewhere you
could substitute life with life
as we know it, you know, base
on carbon with DNA, you know,
we're going to go look a planet
that would have the signatures
of the kind of life that we are.
And I'm just wondering
how you-- is that--
do you think that that's a good
idea because you really doubt
that there could be
weird alternatives based
on other chemical systems?
And the people talked about
silicon and other things
or are you comfortable with
that because what-- how--
we don't even know how to look
for those other forms of life
or do you think we
should broaden our search
for more general principles
of life than just saying,
oh look there's some oxygen
that's some carbon-based life form
gave off.
>> David Grinspoon: I want
to choose all of the above.
We can make the statement that--
we can make the statement
that no one can really imagine
that we can't imagine a life
form say that it's not based
on chemistry, and you might say
more specifically we can imagine one
that's not-- it doesn't function
in water and use carbon molecules.
And I think that's-- I mean we
can fantasize about it but as far
as really defining it
what it might be like,
I think that's a true
statement, but is that a statement
about the limitations of our
own intellect and imagination
or it is a statement
about nature's ability
to invent given the materials
at hand and environments
that we haven't investigated?
So I would-- I support
the current approach,
which is sort of terrestrial centric
and that we are looking for water
and we're looking for
carbon-based life.
And I support it kind of because
it's what we know how to look for
and it's pragmatic and kind
of because I'm not convinced
there is other life that's really
very different.
But we have to always
remember our ignorance
and keep our blinders wide open.
And that's why I also favor
this approach of just looking
for atmospheric dysequilibrium
or looking for anomalous,
just aspects of planets that seem
out of joint, don't seem to be--
you know, consistent with
"natural" or "abiotic processes"
and prepare ourselves
to be surprised.
So I think that we're
doing the right thing,
but we are fooling
ourselves if we trust
that that's the really
the only way to search
and we should always
be open to the universe
for throwing us curve balls.
>> Steven Dick: Yeah.
I would just agree with that.
It's-- I think it's a matter
of priorities now, you know,
a little of-- resources are limited
and you can always, you know,
there are three things,
the scaffolding of life,
the genetics of life and the
solvents involved in life,
you can mix and match all of those
things, you know, carbon, silicon
and RNA and DNA and protein
and water and something else,
but I think right now, the
resources is just part of resources,
but you have to keep
that open mind, right.
>> Bill Mesler: OK.
Thank you.
If you had anymore
questions there's going
to be another Q&A session,
is that right?
For-- with everybody
from the conference.
>> And I'll ask you guys to
stay on stage for just a second.
Hi, Jason from the Kluge
Center, just a quick word
about what's going to happen next.
So our final session of the day
is going be a audience discussion
with all of the panelists.
So if you did not get a chance to
ask a question earlier or you want
to ask more questions, you
have a chance to engage
with all of the panelists.
It will be moderated by Nathaniel
Comfort, our astrobiology chair.
In the next 10 minutes, we are
going to strike the stage and put
up a new stage arrangement,
so that we can ensure all
of our panelists have seats.
And we are also going to be
putting out some food in the back.
That food is for the reception
at the close of the day.
So hold tight, sit through
one more Q&A session,
you get to enjoy the wine,
the cheese, the cookies.
So please don't partake
of that food now.
It will be open for
everyone at 4:30.
So we're going to strike the
stage, we'll put out the food
and then we'll wrap
up with the group Q&A.
[ Applause ]
>> Nathaniel Comfort: OK.
Well, throughout the day
we've been delightfully short
on time for questions.
That's always a good sign when--
for a lively conference,
so that's really nice.
But now is your chance to
ask some of those questions
and any further questions that
you might have for any of us.
And I hope that a lot of this
discussion can start to bounce
around the different
levels of expertise
that we've got up here on stage.
This-- I just want to say you
should feel that what a privilege
and treat this is to have this kind
of range and quality and caliber
of expertise all in one
stage, it's just a phenomenon.
So, I'm just delighted
to have you all here.
I want to ask-- so please if you
have a question, come up to one
of the mics that we have here
and ask it, and I would only ask
that you try to keep your
questions concise and so
that we have enough time
for everybody to ask.
So, you know, no long
expositions and specious please.
We can save those for
the one in [inaudible].
All right, so you can just go
ahead and you can line up if you
like if there is somebody
at the mic,
and you want to go next just
go and stand behind them.
And I'm going to moderate this
in a very light handed way.
We'll see who wants to chime in
and if there is anything I can do
to kind of direct things,
I will do that.
So please by all means come
on up and we can get started.
>> Linda Billings: Hi.
I'm Linda Billings, I work
with the Astrobiology Program
at NASA with Mary Voytek.
I had a question for the writers,
the journalists on the panel,
I would love hear what you thought
about the proceedings of the day.
I'm a social scientist myself and
much of this went over my head,
but it's all fascinating but I
would really like to hear from you.
>> Carl Zimmer: Ah well,
I mean this is stuff
that I write about all the time.
And so, it's a really great
opportunity for me to kind
to step back and kind of get an
overview of the big questions
that are driving the field.
Certainly-- I mean it was sort
of interesting that every now
and then you would see-- you would
see, you know, headlines, you know,
from slide to slide,
and, you know, clearly,
that's a sign of just how
important the origin of life is
and the creation of
life is to the public.
You know, those are fears,
fears appetite for it.
Now, when you get into the details
of ribose, that's, you know,
where the ribose hits the road
and you have to, you know,
try to be a good science writer and
find a way to keep people's interest
if they don't have a PhD in
chemistry, but it's worth it.
And I think it's also useful to
have that historical perspective
and see that, you know, just
how tempting it is to kind
of draw too much out of the
latest research, you know.
And, you know, I don't know if I
have been writing about things like,
you know, like those
radium creatures, you know,
if I have been guilty of that
but that was New York Times.
So, anyway.
[ Laughter ]
>> Nathaniel Comfort: You know,
I would just say Carl
does have great job
of bringing in the history.
He had a story just this
last week and had a really--
really did a great job and actually
got tweeted out by the History
of Science Society, so you
know you're doing a good job.
>> Bill Mesler: Yeah.
I got to say it's an honor
to be here with Carl Zimmer
because he is the best science
writer in the subject of the origin
of life in the country for sure.
I am always struck by-- whenever
I'm at a conference on the origin
of life, I think I'm humbled and
reminded that there is a lot of--
there isn't a lot of the unity on
the answers for these questions,
and it sort of reminds you that I
think as someone who observes it,
I want to be able to say, oh
it's right around the corner
and perhaps it is, but when I
see the divisions among different
scientists in this
field, it strikes me
that perhaps we don't,
we aren't as close yet.
Sorry, Steve, you and me on one
side or the other would you?
But, yeah, I'm always
reminded of that.
And so, it is-- it's
a question that--
it's one of the most
important questions in science,
if not the most important but it's--
and it's one that I hope I
see answered in my lifetime
but I don't know if I will.
>> Nsikan Akpan: And I think--
when I took out the day was
just the ability to sort
of track all of these things.
I would love the fact that we
covered so many different topics
across sort of like the whole
scope of the origins of science.
You know, I'm a journalist who
doesn't necessarily only focus
on the origins of science.
So, it's great to get sort
of like a refresher course.
Then the other thing I enjoyed was
the visuals and their presentations,
you know, for television where
were always thinking of ways
to tell stories visually,
so I'd never really thought everyone
did an exceptional job for that.
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Thanks.
OK, yes? Hi.
>> So hi, I'm [inaudible].
It's a fabulous event.
So my question is mainly
for Steven and David,
but of course anyone else
who wants to chime in.
I want to return this
idea of panspermia,
which Stevie mentioned that, you
know, possibly we're all Martians.
And David, you mentioned that,
you know, Mars and Venus,
both had these areas where they
might have been water worlds.
So my question is, is there
any evidence we have to suggest
that panspermia originating
on Mars might be more likely
than Venus or vice versa?
I'm partly asking from my
background as a climate modeler
where we have a much easier
time getting Venus to be warm
under faint young Sun than mars
to be warm under faint young Sun,
but I'm not sure is there any reason
why we think one or the other.
And actually I have a
quick question that might--
that Steven might answer is
can you conceive of a planet
that might be more conducive to the
origin of life than Earth and might
that had an implication
for panspermia?
>> David Grinspoon: As far
of your first question,
it's a great question.
There might be a slight bias towards
Mars in terms of celestial dynamics.
I think it's probably a little
bit easier or more frequent
to transport stuff from Mars to
Earth than from Venus to Earth just
because Venus has a bigger gravity
well and so that for a given size
of impact or you're going to
less likely to blow chips off
that are going to go into the
orbit and end up at Earth.
However, that may not have
been the limiting factor,
we're to talking early on
during heavy bombardment
that was probably conceived
whether it was a reasonable flocks
of stuff going between all of them,
so that difference might
not that be that important.
As far as early environments,
you know, I'm tempted as of--
I am sort of a Venus guy and
I am tempted to say, you know,
Venus is a tabula rasa,
we don't know anything
about this early environment.
We have some hints.
And so, for all we know, it could
have been by far the best place,
whereas with Mars, we know
of some potential problems
and that there is some weird
unsolved problems of the climate.
But in reality, you know, there
is nothing we know about any
of the three that precludes
an origin of life.
So I would have to
say it's, you know,
it's still pretty up in the air.
>> Steven Dick: Yeah.
I'm wrecking my brain,
trying to figure out a plan
that there might be more
conducive to the origins of life.
The thing is that planets
evolve, you know?
So, you know, we had to go
through the late heavy bombardment,
you know, which ended 3.8 billion
years ago or something like that.
I think, most the planets
in the solar system
at least the inner ones all have
the late heavy bombardment, right?
So I don't see anyway of doing
away with that is probably similar
if the formation of
solar systems is similar
in other planets, on
other solar systems.
But, you know, as I say
planets evolve and, you know,
there was a time when there was
no oxygen on the Earth and oxygen
when it evolved from photosynthesis
really was poisoned, right?
So things had to revolve
based on that.
So, I don't know, do you have
any ideas on that, David?
>> David Grinspoon: I was sort of
glad he directed that one at you.
The fact is, you know, my
impression from listening
to the talks today is, you know,
that is still fundamentally
and unsolved problem
and once we know
that those requirements really are,
we could talk about the
planet that makes them better.
But at this point, I'm kind of bit
of lost to say what that would be.
Steve probably has a better idea.
>> Steven Benner: Yeah, I mean,
first, the gravity is less
to mechanics has all worked
out relatively reliably.
And you can go look it up, there's a
very minor contribution for the fact
that Mars is farther out
from the sun and the Earth.
And, of course, as David mention the
gravitation from Mars is much lower,
but, of course, remember
the atmospheric thickness
of atmospheric has to do
with the size of the impact.
They're both coming
in and going out.
Second, Titan is often
referred to as a place
where you might have
more prebiotic organics.
We don't actually have
a clear understanding
of whether we could
have a warm Titan
that is something that's closer.
If you have a problem with the faint
early sun, it's going to be worst
in titan, which is
like 10 astronomical units
compare to the earth.
So-- But we would be perhaps
better if we have a warmer titan
with an organic richness,
which would be more conducive
maybe to the origins of life.
But as you know that
foremost important words
in science are, I do
not know, right?
So that's where your
focus right know.
There's an interesting possibility.
And remember the argument for
going panspermia has nothing to do
with sort of just, hey,
let's go panspermia.
Panspermia is invoked to
solve particular problems.
So as was mentioned earlier
invoked to solve the problem
that when Lord Kelvin was
talking about, he did not know
about radioactive decay,
he was saying that if the sun is
the best imaginable quality of coal
and we burn it for a
certain period of time,
we know why the mass the sun that
we can't have had 100 of millions
of years of-- and he was
working very hard to find ways
and increasing the life
span of sun by having bodies
in near solar orbit following to the
sun can bring their kinetic energy.
So, panspermia is invoked to
solve a particular problem
in this particular case
about inadequate physics.
Here, where-- we suggest a
life might have come from Mars
to solve a particular problem
which comes from inadequacy
of early modeling, but
it's water modeling,
it's the notion the Earth having
had so much of an inventory of water
and so little plate tectonics
that you were not able
to get dry land necessary to
solve the intrinsic instability
of your early biopolymers with
respect to hydrolysis by water.
But, you know, I just talk
to you what was-- where's--
N2O and there's the nitrogen oxide.
Oh there you are.
OK. Yeah. I mean there's a
whole story that you can get
if you solve the earlier,
faint early sun problem
by better greenhouse effects.
It's certainly easier to
do on Earth than in Mars.
And the facts are that
I find it more likely
that as we understand the early
Earth, we get more and more
of an understanding of an
earlier start to plate tectonics
than we have thought about
it 10 years or 20 years ago,
which means an earlier continents.
And so Steve Mojzsis [assumed
spelling], for example,
is wanting to give us roughly
two California size land areas
of dry land at 4.2 billion years,
which will be more than enough
to not need to go to mars.
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Yes?
>> Anthony Weston: Yeah.
I don't know.
I'm Anthony Weston.
I'm a independent philosopher
and just like to say it's lovely
to be here with you
folks, some of them--
may of whom I've read and
taught in a few occasions
and even reviewed in one case.
But here's the thing, I went--
panspermia came up, I thought,
this is an opportunity to speak to
folks who are all over this field
but central to it in different ways.
To-- just ask you question about
this, does anybody else bugged
by the sexism of it,
this panspermia?
Like seriously, so yeah, we
don't have to talk to this way,
we can talk other ways
for example, panovular,
why don't we try that for a while.
I'm totally serious or let's
say pandermia where at least
so panspermia or panovular
or animalist, right?
So-- but we could have-- it
might be more sensible to have--
>> Bill Mesler: I just have to
say as a feminist to write a book
about the history of this subject.
It's needless to say, it's
a very, very male dominated.
>> Anthony Weston: This
image of event going out
>> Bill Mesler: It made me feel bad.
>> Anthony Weston: Yeah.
>> Bill Mesler: It made
me feel bad to do that.
>> Anthony Weston:
Well, we can change it.
And you folks could change it.
And I'm-- that isn't just that,
you know, this isn't just politics.
I mean people are talking
here about the conceptual--
well, tools of variety of
sorts including different kind
of telescopes, and all, but also
the conceptual tools that we use
to think of all these through.
And so, this is the concept, right?
It inclines us in certain
directions and closes us off
from other ways of thinking.
For example, if you think of
like the panspermias or maybe us
down the road spitting our sperm
all over the universe then you have
to think of other things like
planet is being impregnable--
not impregnable, but yeah, what
I mean is pregnable, right,
the possibility of
making them pregnant.
So there's whole kind
of conceptual frame
that inclines towards certain kind
of space exploration and others.
So what I felt was something that
didn't have to do with seeding
at all, but something
more like invitation.
So paninvitationism [phonetic],
so like the Stephen Hawking
project, what is it called?
Sending out a little chips with--
>> Nano spacecraft.
>> Anthony Weston: Yeah.
There's a name.
Yeah. There's a name for that.
>> Starshot.
>> Anthony Weston: Yeah, Starshot.
So is that-- what kind of--
that's not a spermia of any kind
or an ovular or dermia or
anything that's ascending out of--
kind of an announcement or
sort of invitation to respond.
So it matters what
we call this, right?
It doesn't just-- it's
offensive to certain people.
So I'd like to put that
out there as a plea as well
as something people might want
to response to in the pleas.
Let's change it, you can change it.
You can change it.
And we should.
>> Steven Dick: When you
started your comments,
I thought you were referring
to what to me is a little bit
of a mostly white male elephant
in the room, which is the fact
that they make up--
the gender balance
of our panel is not
reflective of the gender balance
of the gender population or even
that of professionals
in the field, which--
>> Anthony Weston: It's partly--
That's partly reflection
of budget, I have to say.
>> David Grinspoon: Yes.
And, you know, not to be too
hard on anyone but it is--
and it's a longer conversation.
But it's noticeable and
I personally want to--
when it come to that that we all--
professionals have to try to do
a little bit better with that.
A lot better.
And not to diss any individual
or institution-- I love you guys.
And-- But that it's interesting
that the point you did make
about language is one-- you
know, I've heard that in critique
and I've always, in my
mind, thought, well,
but the root of panspermia just
means seed, and seeds are the way
that physically life spreads
form place to place, you know,
and that moves from--
you know, gets--
finds its way to desert
isles on earth, you know?
And so, is it-- if you look at that
root, is that really a gender thing
or is that just a mechanistic thing.
But then, you know,
maybe there's a deep--
deeper level in which I'm
fooling myself, and we do need
to look at that, I don't know.
>> Nathaniel Comfort:
I would just note
that there's a longstanding
metaphor in science and especially
in medicine of seed and soil, as
an idea for conception of disease
and the spread of disease.
This was used extensively
throughout the 19th century and well
into the 20th century, the
notion of disease having
to fall upon fertile
soil in order to take.
And sometimes it falls on barren
soil and then you can be exposed
to the disease but not get it.
So, I think it's a really
interesting point to think
about the gender dynamics of this.
>> Sophia Roosth: Nathaniel,
if I could elaborate
on what you're saying just a bit.
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Yup.
Please, by all means.
>> Sophia Roosth: I think this
question of to what extent rhetoric
or discourse is important
to the way we think
about sciences is something worth
contemplating further beyond just
changing the name for something.
Of course, what we're
trying to do today is talk
about what are the conditions
of life, what makes life emerge.
And the fact to the matter
is that the word sperm,
as we've already discussed,
means seed.
But this goes back to Plato.
And when Plato talks about
where new organisms come from,
he says that the form is
provided by the sperm or the seed,
and then the nutritive environment
where the soil is provided
by the matrix which is where
we get the word mother.
So these are deeply gendered words
but they also inflect
the way we think
about what counts as
meaningful to life.
Is it the material substance or are
we talking about something like form
or pattern that can be simulated?
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Mm-hmm, nice.
>> Steven Benner: I believe
that ma is an Indo-European
word meaning mother.
And matrix is derived from
mother, not the other way
around but maybe I'm mistaken.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
[ Laughter ]
>> Nathaniel Comfort:
Any further comments
on that one or should we move on?
Yeah. OK, please.
>> Vladimir Airapetian:
Vladimir Airapetian,
NASA Goddard Space Flight Center.
Yes. So I want to throw a couple of
ideas about panspermia by itself.
First, if a panspermia really
efficient way to seed life,
then we need certain
concentration of organic molecules
of certain complexity to be of--
to be accumulated in the
aqua and reservoirs on Earth.
That's the first thing.
The second thing that's more
important is the chirality of life.
We know that amino
acids are left-handed.
So, do we know that the
left-handedness is the universal
requirement for life?
And so, unless we've solve this
problem we can't say anything
about panspermia.
>> Steven Benner: Well, OK.
The Burmese python comes to Florida.
Mr. and Mrs. Python
are both necessary
and they land in the Everglades.
And this is a case where
the environment is suited
for reproduction, and
therefore they take
over because they lack a
host-- predator rather.
The other alternative, of course,
is they could land in Everglades
and find that they don't have any
food and that they could go extinct.
So, your problem with being in
Mars, right, you're sitting in Mars,
you are, say evolving, originating
on Mars because you enjoy,
at least your molecules can survive
in a relatively water-poor
environment.
But at some point you might regard
water as a limiting resource just
like many bags here in
the ocean regarding iron
as a limiting resource or
plants regarding nitrogen
as a limiting resource.
So you're sitting in your room
Sunday morning doing the crossword,
you got hit by a meteorite
and got kicked to Earth.
You splashed down on an ocean.
Now, your first possibility
is that you will say, "Hey,
the scare resource, water, which
I have been harboring, conserving,
working very hard to maintain
as a scarce item on Mars,
is all of a sudden
now abundant to me.
I would then burst out like
the Burmese python has done
in the Everglades.
The other possibility, of course,
is that you have adapted to be
at a water-sparing environment,
using whatever water you have.
And when you landed in
an ocean, you just drown.
So, your first question will
be, we don't have a clue
in general as to how that works.
What's your second question?
[ Inaudible Remark ]
All right.
No. We don't know the L-amino acids.
In fact we can make DNA out
of L, which is the opposite
of its natural structure.
We can make proteins out of
D-amino acids and there's no reason,
I think to believe it was.
Yeah, or now there's a lot
of theories on that, right?
So, the set parity
violations of nuclear decay,
the optical polarization
of circularly-polarized
ultraviolet light,
these have all been
involved but we don't know.
>> Bill Mesler: I actually have a
reaction to the chirality question
that I sort of want
to bounce off some
of the more chemically
literate people here,
like Steve for instance, which
is that it always seemed to me
like something that people
work really hard on a solution
for that's not really a problem,
and that, I mean, I understand why
like having a chirality is necessary
for stereochemistry but it seems
to me like that it's just being sort
of an arbitrary random
thing that happened.
And it-- you know, when this
origin of life thing was happening
and then could have been either way
and then once it started,
it self-perpetuates.
And so, it seems sort of very
unprofound to me, the left
or the right, if-- I mean,
stereochemistry makes sense
and if there's organic life, other
places probably uses a chirality.
But it seems to me likely to just
be sort of random and not that hard
to sort of pick one and
then get perpetuated.
Is there really-- Does
there have to be more to it?
>> Nathaniel Comfort: What
Francis Crick would have called a
frozen accident.
>> Bill Mesler: Yeah.
>> Vladimir Airapetian:
Yeah, as far as I understand,
the number of meteorites, the
chemical analysis shows that number
of meteorites show excess
in L. That's really--
>> Steven Benner: Well, it depends.
I mean, what the meteorite
show excess--
or, I mean, Sandra Pizzarello,
George Cooper, NASA Ames,
these people have found asymmetric
excesses of one over the other.
And the question-- the problem that
most of the times that they find
and they have what they call
alpha-methyl amino acids,
which are amino acids
that are not able
to lose their chirality
quite so easily.
But yeah, I mean, I
agree with you, David.
I mean, basically homochirality is
essential for biopolymer evolution.
And that's because when you
evolve and replace amino acid,
you really don't want to do a--
you wanted to do a
side-chain replacement.
You don't want to do a side-chain
replacement the same time
as you do an orientation change.
And so, homochirality is important.
But I suspect, again, the
words are I don't know.
But I suspect that you
pick one or the other,
homochirality being important and
then which you pick is going to be--
and, of course, we'll be very
fortunate when we discover life
on Mars that it's the
other chirality just--
that will show that we're not
necessarily contaminating the sample
that we looked at on Mars
with something from Earth.
>> Vladimir Airapetian: Well,
my proposition would be might be
that there is a certain isotropy,
you know, that for instance related
to the magnetic field to
the polarized electrons
to some environment that
creates certain predisposition,
certain excess.
>> Steven Benner: OK.
Well, there's-- I mean,
there's between 10
and 100,000 paper literature
on this particular subject.
So, circularly polarizing
the ultraviolet light
in the Sagittarius nebula is
preferencing one over the other.
And that could be an
intrinsic source
for chirality in that location.
>> OK.
>> Steven Benner: People-- 10, 000
papers might be an underestimate.
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Let's
get onto another question here.
>> [Inaudible] which were
formed in a Supernova explosions
in a series of, you
know, generations.
The universe formed about
15 billion years ago.
It takes a few billion
years for a star to form,
go through its life
cycle and finally explode
in its several generations.
Before you get to atoms
that are heavy enough
to perhaps support life,
do we have any estimates
of when life could first have been
formed from that point of view?
Is it possible we are the first
life because of that limitation?
>> Carl Zimmer: I'm totally
unqualified to answer your question.
But one thing I will
note is that there's--
I think his name's
Abraham Loeb at Harvard,
has come out with a neat paper
actually suggesting that if you look
at these processes and you look at
sort of the lifetime of the universe
that you'd really expect life to
originate a lot far of in the future
from now, like billions
of years in the future.
So, the suggestion being,
like, "Why is it so hard for us
to find life on other planets?"
Well, we're like that person who
showed up at the party too early
and you're like, "Oh, there's
nobody here," you know?
We showed up too early.
Let's say this is a paper that's on
archive that you can probably muck
around and find that, so.
>> Vladimir Airapetian:
So we could be the first?
>> Carl Zimmer: Yeah.
No, this is like-- this is actually
a statistical argument that,
yes, we are the first.
>> Steven Benner: Yeah.
You're-- The paper that
I've seen is that your--
everyone of your interesting
atoms, your molybdenum and so on,
you are the product on average
of three to the fourth supernova
that you have been through
so you are a star child,
three or four times.
And, yeah, I mean, of course the
only thing is at the metallicity,
as we like to talk about,
is asymmetrically distributed
in the galaxy.
And so, you know, we should be
looking-- And people do that, right?
People look for high
metallicity stars
which have presumably
had more generations
to create the heavy elements.
But you are the products
of three or four supernova
and of-- I mean, how-- 25?
What's the story?
Twenty-five light years away,
four and a half billion years
ago, a supernova exploded.
The shockwave is what
caused the collapse
of the solar nebula to produce you.
Congratulations.
>> You too.
>> Nathaniel Comfort:
All right, yes.
>> Yes. My question is about the
news article which appeared recently
on the earliest form of
fossils ever discovered.
I think David showed a picture.
In that article, they had a photo
from Shark Bay in Australia.
So I'm looking at this
thinking I'm to believe
that the oldest form
of life is still here.
It's gone through all the eons
of change and it's still here,
looking just like it used
to 3.7 billion years ago.
I'm thinking that seems
pretty unlikely.
Or it does say that life
is extraordinarily stable,
or I'm misunderstanding something.
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Well, this
was really biosignature of the--
you know, these aren't even
actually fossils right there.
They're the remains of fossils.
>> Carl Zimmer: No, no.
Well, maybe they showed
the picture just
to show you what a modern
stromatolite looks like.
Because there are still
stromatolites around.
And so this was a stromatolite
back then.
So, you know, I mean, like
it's a "If it ain't broke,
don't fix it" kind of situation.
I mean, it works pretty
well and it's still around.
They're not as common
as they used to be.
Mostly because like animals showed
up and just ruined the neighborhood.
I mean, they're used
to be much more common.
And so actually you have to go--
you have to look harder for
stromatolites than you used to.
But, you know, it--
>> It doesn't strike to as a
meaningful that stromatolite happens
to be very first form of life--
>> Carl Zimmer: No, it's not
the very first form of life.
It's the oldest form of
life that we have found.
And, you know, and that does
speak to the fact that there had
to be hundred of millions of years
of evolution to get to that point
of cell-- those are presumably
cells, DNA, and protein in them
and that-- and with communities
of different species
interacting, cooperating.
Yeah, that's no small feat.
But, you know, it was-- there
could've been hundreds of millions
of years of evolution
leading up to that point.
This is just the oldest sign of
life that people have found so far,
3.7 billion years ago,
the Earth had been
around for 800 million
years already, so.
>> David Grinspoon:
And when we say--
when you say the earliest form
of life, I mean, there's a truth
to that but it's different from like
finding a giraffe that's 3.7 billion
years old and saying,
"Oh, wow, those are--
that's a long standing
form of life."
Because the stromatolite is not
an organism, it's a microbial mat.
It's a way of a community of
microbes deciding to live together
in sort of a horizontal arrangement.
So, there's, potentially,
an argument from biophysics
for as kind of universality of that.
In fact, people talk about
looking for stromatolites on Mars.
Actually, maybe that's a stretch.
But it's less of a stretch in
talking about looking for a giraffe
on Mars because there's sort of a
basic almost physics or, you know,
basic sort of geometry to why a
simple life might arrange itself
in that way on a planet.
>> Which is not a preserved
life form, it's just a bunch
of physical way in which
microbial that's formed.
>> David Grinspoon:
It's an architecture.
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Yeah.
>> That's a very nice picture.
>> Steven Benner: Well, I want to
encourage your sense of skepticism.
Because I passed the stromatolite
around and I got it back
and nobody remarked me and says,
"What the hell do you think you're
doing trying to tell me this is
as a remnant of a life form?
But it is a rock and it's a rock
with precipitated material in it."
So what's you're observing here
is the precipitated inorganic,
insoluble material.
And we want to encourage
you to ask the question
when you encounter somebody like
me saying as you [inaudible],
how could you possibly know that?
Now, they know it, right?
There's a lot of work
that goes in that,
and many, many PhD dissertations.
But, yeah, I mean that's a
good sentiment to have, right?
When someone tells you
[inaudible], for example,
how do you know whether
it's 3.7 billion years?
And the answer is, well, there's
an answer to that question.
I think it was actually
on the paper.
But, yeah, these are the kinds
of questions that you should ask.
And, of course, that's where the--
we try to train the students
to go deeper so that we can--
we'd love asking PhD
candidates, you know, yeah,
do you think water is H2O?
What's the primary
data that say that--
what are the primary data
that say that water is H2O?
>> Carl Zimmer: And those-- And
there are some "fossils" from almost
that old that people don't
think are fossils anymore,
that they were just-- they
looked a lot a like them.
It gets very tricky with things
like microbial mats that old.
It gets really hard to
figure out what's living
and what just this rocks that
look like what you'd expect.
But, yeah, it seems like
this new one, I don't know,
people seemed to be pretty solid
on it although-- You think so?
All right, he thinks so.
>> David Grinspoon: I don't know.
No. Don't listen to me.
I don't know.
I mean--
>> Carl Zimmer: If I had written
the article I would have called you.
>> David Grinspoon: If you go
over the Smithsonian today and go
into National History Museum,
you still see those shops--
carbon specs, which we thought
used to be cyanobacteria
which we don't think are there.
They're still in the
Smithsonian as example of life.
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Yeah, yeah.
OK.
>> Steven Benner: Right
by that big elephant.
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Yes.
>> Hi there.
I'm with the Richard
Dawkins Foundation
and the Center for Inquiry.
My question is to you, scientists
and science communicators,
you still have to operate
within a political environment,
and it determines what
resources you have,
it determines whether you
have freedom of inquiry.
So I'm asking you, what
is the current status
of the political environment
in which you operate?
And are there any danger signs
that you're concerned
about down the road?
[ Laughter ]
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Let's
keep this nonpartisan.
Everybody is passing.
>> David Grinspoon: I don't
know why people are handing me
the microphone.
[ Laughter ]
I--
>> You're not going to
have equal opportunities.
>> David Grinspoon:
Yeah, that's right.
Personally, I mean, I'm
hesitating because I don't feel
like I have a really profound--
I mean, it's an important
question you asked.
With this particular area of
inquiry I don't feel a lot
of political pressure.
I mean, out there in our society
there are the forces that, you know,
want to teach-- you know, that are
concerned about teaching evolution
in the schools and, you know, the
stuff that you guys at the Center
for Inquiry are very well aware of.
And, you know, those are things
we're aware of but they're not--
you know, it's not affecting
our ability right now
to do the research we do.
It's certainly, you know, affecting
our ability to, in a larger sense,
communicate and have a
science literate society,
which is a wider concern.
And, of course, you know, in my
area of astrobiology which has to do
with climate modeling, I'm,
you know, working with people
who are feeling the effects of
some of the slight, you know,
inquisition like aspects
of some corners
of our government's approach
to climate [inaudible].
And so, you know, there
are some danger signs
on the dashboard, some
lights flashing.
But, you know, as far as
there's nobody telling us not
to research the origin of life or
anything like that, there's no sort
of acute political constraint
on this area of inquiry.
But I think you know as
members of a society at large,
the concern of science
and education,
there are certainly some things
we need to pay attention to.
>> Steven Benner: Can I turn
the question back to you?
Although you seem to
have disappeared, what--
I mean you work at something with
the Richard Dawkins in the name.
So, what is your experience?
>> Well, I run the Richard Dawkins
Foundation for Reason and Science.
And we promote atheism
and scientific literacy.
>> Steven Benner: So you
have a more direct contact
to the public than--
I mean, I talk--
>> And, you know, we--
>> Steven Benner: -- Richmond
society I talk creations all the
time, but you have a more
closer contact to this.
And what's your experience?
>> Well, I work in a realm where
I'm trying to debunk mythologies.
And people cling to those
ideas and are very hostile
to anyone who challenges them.
I would say when you're
dealing with pure science,
it's easier to put forth ideas
often-- to be perfectly frank,
they're a little over the head of
most average people, laypeople.
So, they're not going to be
challenging you directly.
But we run a program, for
instance, the Teacher Institute
for Evolutionary Science School,
where we teach middle school
teachers how to teach evolution.
And we receive, on a daily
basis, responses from teachers
that say they can't
teach the subject.
The kids will turn their chair
to the wall rather than listen
to something that defies what
they've been taught by their pastor,
their priest, their minister,
their imam, the rabbi.
>> Steven Benner: Would
you say that's increasing?
Decreasing?
Do you have any reason
to make a statement?
>> Well, I don't know.
I mean, I do know that
43% of Americans say
that human beings arrived
on this Earth fully formed
within the last 10,000 years.
>> Steven Benner: Because
I talk a lot
to the Gainesville
creationist community.
I just gave a talk, you know,
what religion is that science--
what science is that
religion is not.
The subtitle for that talk is, "Why
scientist do so very little of it?"
But the bottom line is
that they're nice people.
They don't seem to be--
not in kind of hostility.
They-- Of course, the public,
even the creationists very
much values the technology.
The new medicines, the new,
you know, therapies and stuff
that is coming from
science as whatever that is.
Many of them are more concerned
about whether their daughter
is going to come home pregnant
or they're going to be--
you know, they're worried
about the social decay,
they're worried about all sorts
of other things for
which origins of life,
or evolution is a proxy, right?
It doesn't really say
it's a sort of authority.
They don't actually much care.
There's no constructive reason
to care one way or other
when the Earth was formed.
I mean, how does that
influence their daily life,
but it does influence
their daily life
that their kid come home
drug addicted, for example,
and they're worried about the
laws of authority that would tend
to prevent drug addiction, at
least that's how they view it among
their children.
But-- So you actually think
that their-- I mean is it--
>> I think there are direct
societal consequences to that kind
of scientific illiteracy
in the general population.
>> Steven Benner: Well,
I agree with that, but--
>> And I think that there are
consequences for resources
for science and public policy.
From stem cell research, to,
you know, abortion rights,
to same sex marriage,
to climate change.
So-- And I wish scientists
would get a little more engaged
in these battles, because
we need you.
>> Nathaniel Comfort: OK.
We have a couple of
repeat questions.
I want to get to people who
haven't asked a question first
and then we'll get to you.
So, OK.
>> OK. And that is, you know, we've
spoken about the origins of life
and the difficulties
of defining life.
And, you know, we talked
about DNA, RNA.
But it seems to me that what we--
at least what I think is
what's really interesting,
the really interesting life
on Earth, the people all
around us are-- is eukaryotic life.
And can we imagine intelligent
life arising with life forms
that have not experienced
a eukaryotic threshold?
Is there some other path that
people have at least thought about?
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Meaning is
a membrane-bound nucleus necessary
for higher--
>> For most interesting
multicellular life.
>> Nathaniel Comfort:
For a development
of a neural system or
something like that?
>> Yes. Because, I mean,
you know, we're thinking
about the first step
we've got microbes.
Hurray, we've got microbes.
Which is most of what
we've had on Earth.
But the part that makes
our heart beat is
when you start getting
eukaryotes and multicellular life
and complex life with
tissues and organs.
And I'm wondering, has
there been any thought given
to how complex life with
tissues and organs and this sort
of thing might have a reason in the
absence of a eukaryotic threshold?
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Let me
throw in there just into the mix,
whether that question really is
about the transition from one
of the major forms of information
exchange being lateral gene
transfer, shifting toward a
more vertical gene transfer
and the invention of sex.
Possibly another way of
phrasing the question.
>> Matthew Schrenk: I just
also like to add that some
of the things we talked about
recently, the stromatolites,
the biofilms earlier today,
horizontal gene exchange,
all these are-- perhaps they
don't immediately translate
into intelligent life back and
send out signals to other planets.
But these are the beginnings
of differentiation
and these microbial communities are
working together at some skills,
sensing the environment,
having feedbacks
with their underlying
biochemistry, and differentiating.
And so, even before you have
nuclei; you have systems reacting
to the environment and
differentiating it in ways
that are more complex than
they can individually.
>> Nathaniel Comfort:
Biofilms can be differentiated
into different kinds of--
>> Matthew Schrenk:
Yeah, I mean exactly--
>> Nathaniel Comfort:
As you were saying.
>> Matthew Schrenk: You know,
what facilitates the layering
in stromatolites and what
facilitates antibiotic resistance
amongst biofilms in many cases.
So there's a lot of evidence
of these microbial communities
working together in that sense.
>> Steven Benner: Let me see, if I--
I'm assuming that you
would the story rather
than the statement
we don't know, right?
So here's the story.
>> I know we don't know.
>> Steven Benner: You
know we don't know.
>> Has somebody thought
about this more than I had?
>> Steven Benner: Absolutely.
>> Nathaniel Comfort: Oh sure.
>> Steven Benner: So
here's the story.
Monocellular life emerged, we don't
quiet know well Cambrian explosion
is a very clear statement as to
when fossilizable forms 542
million years ago, is the number.
And the story is that's
associated with the arise
of atmospheric oxygen, right?
Because the argument is the
oxygen, O2, and oil that is lipids,
have a huge potential energy
difference between them
as you run your car
by burning gasoline
and that multicellular life
requires that huge amount of energy
and therefore multicellular
life require the emergence
of atmospheric oxygen.
Second point is atmospheric
oxygen is almost certainly arising
from photosynthesis, the
cyanobacteria that we talked
about are generating
dioxygen into the atmosphere.
And then you can look at maybe
two and half billion years ago,
there's a little rise in oxygen.
But the real ramp up of oxygen
is roughly the same time
as the emergent of multicellularity.
Eukaryoticness, which
is a different--
You use that word, right?
The idea of this nucleus membrane
having a differentiated cell
and all the rest of it, is it
required for multicellularity?
Well, any good microbiologist will
tell you that unicellular organisms
by forming this mass,
and you just set this,
are multicellular in
some sense of a term.
But in an organism, if they find
specimen of multicellularity
that you are with a backbone
and the ability to walk
without an exoskeleton so
you can grow without having
to shed your skin and all the rest
of these things, this is something
that is argued to be associated
uniquely with eukaryotic life based
on the ability to have
sex, which you just heard.
And that's an important
way of increasing the rates
of evolution for adaptation.
Now, second question is you have
to do about likelihood, right?
Let's just-- speaking around
that, the sun will last
for what, 10 billion years.
But the sun would grow to a
red giant and consume the orbit
of the Earth and make
Earth an inhabitable say
after five billion years--
I'm speaking around.
So you can say I got life on
Earth within the first 15 seconds
after the Earth emerged in terms
of microbes, but it took me four
and half billion years to get the
fine specimen that is now standing
at that microphone, which just means
that the sun is almost
done, done with you, right?
So you can say that microbial life
easy by that metric, fine specimens
of life able to use this microphone
are difficult by that metric.
But in order to have
intelligence and the ability
to communicate is a very rare
item, because at least on Earth,
it took a long time that most
of the life of the habitability
of this particular rock for it to
immerge, how does that do for you?
>> Thanks to both of you.
>> Nathaniel Comfort: OK.
One more here and we'll
do round two.
>> Yeah, I just want to add
the-- in the next billion years,
the sun will increase its
luminosity by 10% and we're going
to start the-- see the effects
of the runway greenhouse.
It's a--
>> Steven Benner: When, when, when?
>> It's at 10 % every billion years.
>> Steven Benner: OK, got you.
>> In next-- In a billion years,
so we don't need 10 billion years.
>> Steven Benner: When I
should move back to Mars?
>> In a billion-- In a half
a billion years to be--
yeah, but what I want to say just to
comment to the question about the--
when universe became habitable?
There is a paper written
by Mario Livio
from Space Telescope
Science Institute, who--
he did calculations of
production of carbon, oxygen,
and nitrogen as a result of
the three alpha reactions,
and then iron and more
heavy elements.
So you need at least seven
billion years, so that's--
so basically they're half--
we're half away through.
The first half billion years, the
universe was completely stir out.
So we're lucky-- we're not
lucky, it's just probably
that the right place to be here.
So, just a clarification.
The paper is there, I
can give a reference.
>> Nathaniel Comfort: OK.
>> Thank you.
>> Nathaniel Comfort:
All right, yes?
>> My questions is for Sophia.
We saw earlier with one of the
first questions in your talk
that the way we talk about science
and the way scientists
do experiments
to fit narratives can change how
those explorations are investigated,
right?
So looking at synthetic--
>>Sophia Roosth: How
do those investigated?
>> So looking at synthetic life,
we can get something to work,
so we simply it and then they get
to the model that we want, right?
So during your ethnographic
investigation,
you investigated synthetic
biologist, right?
>> Sophia Roost: Yes.
>> And so did you find any other
cultural or rhetorical biases
that were similar to that?
>> Sophia Roosth: Many
although with the caveat
that I wouldn't refer
to them as biases--
>> Sure.
>> Sophia Roosth: --
sciences, cultural,
and social all the way down.
So of course whenever we look
at how scientists are thinking
about the living world, you will
see aspects of society and culture.
And then that's the
reasons why we have a field
like the history of science.
>> So more salient ones, I guess?
>> Sophia Roosth: Yes.
So, there are number of things that
I identified throughout my years
of ethnographic research.
One of the things that I found
most intriguing was the ways
in which something really simple
like biological relatedness, right,
otherwise known as taxonomy,
has to be radically reconfigured
when it comes to talking about
microbes that bear genes that come
from diverse organisms, right?
So what is that?
Where does that fit
on the tree of life?
If it has-- you know, using
the examples that I talked
about in like-- talked
earlier, genes from petunias
or hyperthermophiles
or something else.
And this was something
that was a live question
from any synthetic biologist in the
ways in which they discussed it,
drooped on a lot of social
and cultural assumptions
about how people are
related to one another,
but also about what the
ground for how we would think
about living relatedness
or even a category
like species is defined over time.
And I think it lost count-- I read a
paper that said that there are more
than 57 working definitions for
what is a species as of, I think,
two years ago, that could be found
in the scientific literatures.
So terms like that are
incredibly capacious,
and I mean different
things depending
on what sub-discipline
in you're from.
>> Thank you.
>> Nathaniel Comfort: All right,
we have time for one more
question, I'm afraid.
And then we can have further
informal conversation during
the reception.
So, we'll give this one to you.
Jake, I'm sorry but
we can grab your--
grab the speakers over a
glass of wine, all right?
Yes?
>> Professor Roosth, you in your
talk, you quoted a scientist
who said "I only understand
what I create."
And, of course, I mean,
they thought what
if you create something
you don't understand?
And I like to take that,
and to Professor Grinspoon,
you have great optimism
about the sapient, zoic era.
And, you know, when we think about
the vast explosion of knowledge
that we've had in our lifetimes,
you know, I tend to be optimistic.
But is progress a comfortable
disease?
And we are at a point,
certainly we learned recently
that man can induce earthquakes.
And so, are we perhaps entering into
a strangely world here and I just
to open that up to anybody?
>> David Grinspoon:
Well, it's interesting.
I love the two parts
of your question,
because in the certain
sense, our problem right now,
is that we created
something we don't understand
with our global technological
civilization
and its effect on the world.
So there you go, Richard Feynman.
But, you know, and I just want
to say, you know, you refer--
>> Sophia Roosth: Well,
what Feynman well wrote was
"What I cannot create,
I do not understand."
Which is a very different
kind of claim.
This is about how making something
further is a more comprehensive
and deep understanding of it.
>> David Grinspoon: Right.
So then-- So that doesn't imply
that everything we
create, we can understand.
>> Sophia Roosth: Not at all.
>> David Grinspoon: Yeah, OK.
That's-- Thank you for
that clarification.
But, you know, in relation
to optimism,
I just want to say,
it's complicated.
And, actually, part of my book I
have a whole taxonomy of pessimism
and a whole taxonomy of
optimism where I kind
of break that down a little bit.
Because it's-- I don't see this
binary, although people tend to.
And I certainly don't want
to minimize the challenges
of the next century or
couple of centuries.
You know, they're huge.
But I do think that with
climate change and so forth
and the possible-- you know, the--
some of the bad scenarios
where you see a horizon a lot
of displaced people and
refugees and all of that.
We're talking about the
21st century possibly being
as bad as the 20th century.
Where if you think of the wars and
famines and the mass displacement
and so forth, I mean-- you know,
we made through the 20th century
so we think, "Oh, that
wasn't so bad."
But it was for a lot
of people, right?
And so, I think, you
know, climate wave is--
climate change is this wave
that we're sailing into now.
And we are going to--
there is another side.
There will be a human race and
some sort of global society.
So, it's not an either-- or people
tend to think of it as either/or.
It's a trajectory.
And, you know, human beings have
two ways of learning about things.
There's the good-- to
simplify, there's the good way
where we see what's
coming and we anticipate
and we take corrective maneuvers.
We're not so good at
doing that collectively.
And there's the bad way where
we react to calamity right?
And it's going to be some
combination of the two.
And so it's a complex
range of trajectories
that we're going to navigate.
And there is another side.
And I think that even with
some of the bad scenarios,
there's ultimately a
glorious future but not
without some pain and casualty.
So, I am, in a long time
scale, I'm optimistic but I--
that's actually fairly qualified.
>> Carl Zimmer: I would just add
that, I mean, one form of life
that we haven't talked
about is artificial life.
And so, you know, so there's
a case where you're trying
to build something and,
you know, you're all--
you're totally in control
as the scientist, you know,
programming a computer to have like
virtual life forms inside of it.
And, you know, there are
people at Michigan State
who have developed a system called
Avida where they basically get--
let the systems evolve-- basically
a little program to evolve
and solve problems adding
numbers, doing math,
doing all sorts of things.
And, you know, it's
all deterministic.
You can see exactly what happened
and they followed all the principles
that you built in a sort of an
evolution happening in the computer.
And then they get this thing that
works and then they tried to look
at it and understand how it works
and they don't understand it.
They can't-- It doesn't look like
a computer program any human wrote.
And they can't-- it's very hard
to figure out how it works.
And so, I don't actually
think that being able
to create something is a
guarantee of understanding it.
And, you know, maybe the future like
the machines will be replacing us,
and if we program them with
evolutionary principles,
we have no idea how they're going to
be working a billion years from now.
And then they could just go
off into space and not worried
about the sun burning up, I guess.
[ Laughter ]
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Nathaniel Comfort: OK.
I think that's optimistic
note on which to end.
So, I would like [inaudible].
[ Inaudible Remark ]
Yes. OK. Well, I just want
to thank you all, once again,
for participating and really
making it a very lively
multidisciplinary day.
I've had a great time.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Well, this was something.
Today's symposium really
has given us a lot of rich
and diverse food for thought.
And if you're like me, you
probably want another opportunity
to mold these things over and
think about them and hear some
of the discussions again and listen
to the questions and
the answers again.
And fortunately, you'll have that
opportunity, because in about six
to eight weeks, we hope,
this will be available.
The programs were taped
today or recorded today
and they will be available on the
Library's website, which is loc.gov,
as well as the Kluge Center
website, loc.gov/kluge.
So you will have another
chance to reflect
and think about these things.
So, in closing, I would like to
thank all of the participants
in today's symposium for
their thoroughly-engaging
and thought-provoking presentations.
Thank you all.
But I would especially like
to thank Nathaniel Comfort
for organizing this event
and for serving us a catalyst
for such an exciting
exchange of ideas.
And it has been a privilege to
have you here at the Kluge Center.
Thank you all for coming today.
And please join us
for some refreshments
and continue the conversation.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.